I'm good evening my name's Molly jars
I'm carrying this evenings planning
committee this is a meeting that is
public but the participation is
regulated by registration so I will now
ask the officers to introduce themselves
Olivia Quinn committee services Ross
Ross changes from legal services my name
is David Jeffrey I'm the western area
team leader in my role as an impartial
adviser to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues that arise doing so
I am bound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute planning committee members are
not bound by the case officers
recommendation or by oral advice
Victoria Chataway a Senior Planner thank
same walk she County Council highways
good evening John Kerr food policy
manager Enterprise housing planning this
Trafford District Council staff velocity
planning officer Alan Abbas planning
officer thank you 20 titan-1 on the
agenda are there any apologies for
absence apologies from councillor
carriage who can sir fielding
substituting for and Counting Audrey
thank you members are there any
disclosures of interest councillor organ
thank you to contact on 1801 oh six one
on the various Arden Heath's
applications both involved with this
development at outline stage but I
consider that that does not fit in my
judgment at this reserve matter stage
and I will withdraw for 1900 for nine
one as I consider that I am prejudiced
Thank You Chancellor Perry thank you and
good evening chair I am the county
councillor for the wells borne division
which incorporates snitterfield however
I come to the meeting with an open mind
so
I will continue to sit on committee for
that particular application and
councillor Richards thank you can also
Giles I am the ward member for the same
application I will be vacating my seat
to speak Thank You anyone else counts
Laban's thank you think all of committee
received an email from mr. Olens in
relation to the first application thank
you
turning to item 3 the minutes are
attached to the agenda of the 13th of
March does committee approve those
minutes thank you right now to move to
the substantive matters committee we'll
first deal with application 18 / 0 1 0 6
1 land to the north and west of Bishop
turn lane if I could ask invite officer
to present the application thank you
Thank You chair this is a reserved
matters application pursuant to outline
reference 15 Oh double four double nine
out which granted consent for access to
the site and the development of up to
512 the site is located at the north to
the north and west of Bishop to main and
is indicated by the black dot this is
the red line boundary of the site and it
shows the site in context the further
context this is an aerial photo of the
site I have shown the red line just for
an a an additive processes and and it
seeks to show the the site within the
context of the area for information that
a 46 is the road you can see to the
north of the site to the to the south is
Bishop turn lane the long road to the
south and east to the west is the
Ridgeway and to the north is the the
canal surrounding the site you can see
existing residential development in the
area outline stage and approved
parameter there was no parameters plan
this is shown here in addition access
plans were agreed outline stage and are
not for consideration under this
application the parameters plants sets
our areas where housing could be located
and where open space should be located
this includes a setback distance for
housing of 35 meters from the a46
as a reserved matters application this
submission seeks to agrees the matters
of appearance landscaping layout
unscaled as of noted access was agreed
outline and is not a matter for
consideration here
Reserve matters have to be made in line
with the outline consent and as such a
reserved matters application should only
look at those matters reserved from
outline and any information that is
required via condition are set at the
outline stage in relation to this
particular application there were a raft
of section 106 matters agreed which are
detailed on pages 12 to 13 of your
agenda and a total of 33 conditions were
imposed outline of those five are were
required to be submitted with details at
reserved matters stage they're listed on
this slide
and information has been submitted in
relation to all five of these conditions
of particular influence to the reserved
matters of landscaping layout appearance
and scale are condition for which
relates to housing mix and condition 11
which relates to the design code during
the course of this application the
housing mix has been significantly
altered to accord with the NDP and this
is also resulted in the loosening of the
grain of the development in achieving a
smaller dwelling types in relation to
the design code this was a document that
was required to be agreed prior to this
mission of a reserved matters
application with the purpose of setting
clear design objectives that would steer
the reserved matters this is just taken
from the agreed design code and sets out
the things that were included in that 75
page document and include but sort of an
analysis of the area the contacts in
character character of the area
what should then be included in in the
reserved matters in terms of
King Street hierarchy block structure
and legibility through the site and also
looking at things like architectural
details that should be included as a
consequence of that design code and
following negotiations throughout the
application post as the developer has
now arrived at this layout plan the
context again that a46 is at the top of
the plan and Bishop to name to the south
the access is that were agreed are shown
on this plan and you can see blocks of a
small to medium scale across the site
with properties facing out onto public
realm and it seeks to show the
permeability through the site you can
also see in the northern section the
site the proposed play area and the
community orchard this is a connections
plan for the site now as access was
agreed at outline stage this reserved
matters cannot look at how else to
access the site but it can look at
internal road layout and pathways to
ensure that there is logical routes
through the site to get to destinations
such as the play area and that watered
and to get from any house on to the
surrounding area this slide shows that
play area that's proposed for this site
the section 106 required this to be
submitted as a locally a clip equipped
area of play since the application has
been submitted the amount of play
equipment has increased to what's now
presented to you and cycle racks have
also been added to encourage people to
cycle through the site additionally
added since the application has been
submitted is trimmed trail equipment
along the site this wasn't required as a
section 106 but has been added to try to
encourage exercise and activity
throughout the site
it's very hard to depict street scenes
because when you've got a large plan in
front of you it's easier to see them
than it is on this screen so this is
purely there to show you this is sort of
detail that's being submitted and in
each street scene both developers house
types are within them this is another
street scene across the site but for
clarity the developer has provided CGI's
so this CGI if you can see at the top of
the screen there's an overall layout of
the site and there's a little red blob
the red blob indicates what this CGI is
seeking to show so this is facing onto
Bishop turn lane and again shows both
house develop house types from both
developers this is a cgi again the red
blob on the plan shows what the area
that it shows so this is looking from
the public open space proposed into the
site you can make out the bungalows that
are proposed as part of the site and
again it shows both house developers
house types finally this is a CGI onto
the Ridgeway it shows both developers
house types ad it shows some of the
corner turning properties that are
proposed across the site Thank You chair
the recommendation is to approve subject
to conditions and there are no updates
if I could now call to speak
George Dunn and Mark Rowland's
yes what yes that's fine what I
understand is you're sharing your time
with mr. which one who's who's sorry
that will help me thank you thank you
so I understand you've yes I understand
you've agreed to share the time so a
minute and a half each is that correct
yes so what I propose to do is maybe
hear from you first and then when it
gets to a minute and a half I'll let you
know and the clock will stop and then we
can turn to you if that's okay okay so
we're clock will start from when you
start speaking
so yes you just pushed me thank you
please tell me when to start up to 500
well there is considerable examples of
similar developments in the Midlands
having been scaled down following
initial outline planning application
pages 5 & 6 of the council committee
report for today we summarized the
problems with the size of the proposed
development in addition to concern
expressed by grads bishops and broad
residents and others including
counselors therefore developer should be
advised that it's necessary to reduce
the number of dwellings on this side a
scale down plan was given to the
developers which they have ignored NPP
guidelines are long counselors to
advocate wherever or not the development
consists of too many Weller's there is
overwhelming evidence that this
particular development consists of an
excessive number of dwellings that in
NPP had turned if not a sustainable
development that fits the local content
and policy see as I entry exit to and
from the whole site should be from to
exist
in roads and not as proposed by the
developer whereby 80% have to enter exit
to the site only from one road mandatory
safety isn't it
in an emergency should be paramount for
all bishop involved the residents who
use the roads
latest Warwick Highway statement in
March 2019 to Stratford planning state
the site layer is still subject to
technical approval and the highways act
for 1980 arrangements may be required
thank you very much but achieved it's
not long minute and a half okay thank
you so the latest proposal is still
flawed in multiple ways and urge you to
defer it a lot of this committee are
retiring or facing D selection in the
coming elections it's only right that
the future committee should be held
accountable not the exiting committee
there's been a lack of process all the
way through this and we were lied to at
the alkaline planning stage we were told
that only the in principle the
development was being negotiated and the
access points we're now told that almost
nothing is negotiable
the layout was already defined and we're
down to talk about the color of the roof
tiles so key points which you've had in
an email homie the scale needs to be cut
back need to take account of criticism
from sports England but there's no
sporting facilities the layout needs to
be redesigned because eventually that
canal bridge will have to be rebuilt and
that will probably mean realigning it so
please don't the doctors get a layout
which doesn't allow a new bridge to
connect to it Elizabeth Dixon from
accessible Stratford has criticized the
lack of improvements for road layout and
wheelchair mobility access so we
proposed a new bridge for foot foot
passengers and cyclists over the bridge
and for all the predictions about noise
please impose a condition that says if
your calculations are wrong then the
developers have to put in some kind of
stick war and the pace of the project
was so desperate to fill a housing needs
why is it going to take seven years we
think minimum three years should be
required fairly time thank you very much
committee do you have any questions for
either gentleman mr. bonds at the
outline stage there was a bit of a ding
dong on whether there was one or two
instances because the bridge is owned by
charity and can't be changed by the
county council so we have got more
entrants in you same as we did
originally up to it's my thoughts were
correct so I'm not talking about the
number of entrances or changing any of
that all I'm saying is when that bridge
does eventually need to be rebuilt and
Warwickshire County Council would like
you to be rebuilt in a different form to
eliminate the hump
then it inevitably needs to realign from
its current line on to bishops and Lane
more skewed onto the new development
land at the moment they plan to put
houses there our proposal is that there
should be a roundabout or some space
left there so that we don't forever
regret the fact that we built houses
where really the new bridge should be
realignment okay I have a question in
terms of the comments you made about
lack of wheelchair access does that
relate to the bridge or issues with the
site I just wonder if you could expand
for me
so the comments were specific to using
the bridge thank you thank you if I
could now invite Helen Dawkins to speak
please thank you you have three minutes
from when you current speaking condition
leveled the outline planning permission
for the site required the submission of
a design code to fully address this code
a steering group was set up which
included ourselves the developers
elected members council officers and
community representatives on behalf of
Bragg's the first day and group meeting
took place in January 2017 in a total of
seven steering group meetings were held
where extensive discussions took place
to agree the content of the design code
which was approved in April 2018 the
approved design code set site clearly
the principles and key design parameters
to guide any reserved matters
application for this site towards high
quality design developing an
architectural style and character areas
for the site and finer detail a reserved
matters application comprised fully with
this approved design code adopting the
key design elements for example the use
of corner houses
joël aspect Heist types to articulate
corners Gateway buildings and nodal
points to create a distinctive sense of
place a variety of house types have been
used for either development avoiding the
use of standardized types but instead
incorporating distinct architectural
details for example use of Tudor
boarding finials dental brickwork
courses variation of window and porch
stars chimneys in the palette of
high-quality materials a fabric first
approach has been taken to design
carried through from the design code to
minimize the deep the demand for heat
and power through an energy-efficient
fabric services along with the provision
of wiring for electric vehicle charging
points throughout the course of the
application
a number of significant positive
improvements have been made to the
scheme these include addressing the
highs in mix increasing the play
provision and improving highway
connections to write the site linking up
the Ridgeway and Bishop turn lane to the
wider area encouraging both cycling and
walking on the matter of heisting mix
the first application submission amaz'd
proposed a market and affordable housing
mix fully in accordance of policies h6
and h7 been adopted plan in December
2018 Stratford published their
neighborhood plan which prescribed a
slightly different mix to the local plan
in light of this the developers
undertook further consultation with the
Tyne Council to discuss the heisting mix
and other design matters and as a result
the heisting mix and I fully accords
with the neighbourhood plan in addition
from the town council meeting the play
provision on site has been amended to
incorporate additional equipment which
is over and above the obligation set
height and approved section 106
agreement play area and I contains 11
seconds of equipment and nine pieces of
trim trail equipment over all the
reserved matters application fully
complies with the approved design code
and along with the positive additions
and enhancements is highlighted to you
we considered at the scheme will deliver
a successful well-designed a much-needed
heisting development I would recommend
that committee follow the off of offices
recommend recommend a shinto approve
Thank You committee any questions no the
Planning Director for Miller homes but
I'm speaking on behalf of Miller homes
and tail Olympics it's a joint applicant
it's all intersperse so the land split
is where each parcel or phase that we
have we've got an element in each phase
so if you if you like if you take the
first parcel it's more or less 50/50 in
that bit the next parcel before you get
to the school 5050 in that bear
and then likewise it's all pretty much
have to feel like the development so
we've tried to make it so it's
indistinguishable of so you can pick out
which developer is and hence why we've
also worked quite extensively on our
house types as well count slippery Thank
You chair good evening
I wonder whether you could just expand
upon the build-out rate on the basis
which was highlighted by one of the
previous speakers because obviously
you're looking at around 71 houses per
year if you're taking 500 units over
seven years there are two developers
it's quite normal to be about sort of 70
70 units per year for one developer just
like an explanation is why you think it
would take seven years to build a - it's
more likely to probably take less than
that I'd probably say it's more of a
five year period
melih homes work on a sales rate of one
per week so if we can build at that rate
we obviously will do it just depends on
market conditions really in terms of the
sales rate sometimes you can get a
faster sales rate depending on what the
market is doing at that particular time
other times it can be slower but I think
it's probably more really realistically
a five year period I just wanted to ask
you about the landscaping firstly in the
public space I think from one of the I
think graphic images we showed I mean
it's sometimes find with these sites
that the open space is open yeah but
it's not particularly attractive and
it's already doing anything particularly
around the attenuation features I'm just
wondering if you can explain that what
might be done here to address that if
you see what I mean because you can have
like a basically a patch of grass that's
fenced off but it doesn't it's not got
its own design in a way we don't we
don't intend to fence off the
attenuation ponds they will feature as a
part of the open space and I guess that
another reason for the incorporation of
the trim trail if you look there's quite
a linear area of open space to the north
along there
again that's where we've incorporated
the elements of trim trail so it's
adopted around there too to be able to
make it more usable and clearly the
community orchard was in that area as
well to break that up a bit and the
other thing we've tried to do is is
create as much connectivity within that
open space so people can walk around
that's walk around or cycle around those
areas of public open space so tried to
integrate it as much really as opposed
to closing areas off
there's only tree planting do you know
proposed around the attenuation features
in those particulars I know you've got a
community orchard there will be some
elements of ad hoc tree planting yeah I
mean that that particular door in there
doesn't show the landscaping right all
of its detail that they're also subject
to separate drawings how would the
applicant feel if there was no not
necessarily a condition about
consideration for some wildflower
planting I'm thinking particularly
because they're dry attenuation ponds
whether they can be maybe made more
their future can't be cats go across the
top of my head but I'm pretty sure there
is some wildflower or some Reed bad type
landscaping within those attenuation
features to add to the biodiversity of
that okay so yeah if you wanted to add
that on it if it was felt as there was a
late to applicant like sorry just one
second
yes you've heard the object has raised
concern about density and essentially
whether it is possible for this
application essentially to be scaled
back and to be loop so I just wondered
if you had a response to that the
outline application is for up to 500
Whelan's we have put 500 dwellings on
the site we don't feel as though we've
actually four could use the words
crammed those dwellings on the site each
dwelling has more than adequate amenity
area Gardens and therein you know it's a
fairly normal density for a housing
development of this size council
fielding know each developer will have
their own production team in terms of
doing the buildings what we will have is
we join part of what we call a
consortium so the joint infrastructure
so that the main roads right the site
that will be done jointly by both
developers and any individual parcels of
the residential units will then be done
by each developer yeah that concern yeah
you mentioned that there had been a
steering group which included residents
could you tell us the composition of
that group some of the issues you
discussed in relation to the two
objections objectives we've heard and
was there sort of harmony in all aspects
in the recommendations or the
application yeah as I mentioned we had
seven steering group meetings all in all
and that comprised of consistently
members to members of the residents
group attending and the same team
members attended that meeting there were
also members Ward members
local tan councilmembers and it was
chaired by councillor Pendleton
throughout the process and yeah they
were meetings where we discussed the
content of the design group and then the
drafts were also discussed in their
building there's the main act main round
by off Bishop ttan Road and then there's
the entrance off the Ridgeway in terms
of construction we will have to submit a
construction environmental management
plan which I believe is a condition on
the outline plan Bishop does the main
right way and there's the one forever on
time no it's the canal bridge and that's
all yes Chancellor Fielding seen there's
anyone access from British cameras to -
you said the Ridgeway and yes there's
one off the ridge way too often I was
just going to say the issue is access
has already been approved so it's not a
matter for this committee okay any other
questions No thank you very much
if I can invite council of Audrey Thank
You Council Audrey have up to five
minutes
members of the committee are I want to
respectfully request that you defer any
decision tonight and allow a new
committee to have a site visit to
understand what's going on on this site
and given they've got to live with the
consequences of it they should be
responsible over the next four years of
their term this site we've heard is up
to five hundred homes and the developer
has admitted they're going to build 500
there it's I understand but with the
largest site within the Town of
Stratford that's that's seeking to be
built over the next period so it is
material to Stratford and it is clearly
extremely material to the residents who
live in Bishop t'en who have concerns
and I acknowledge Bragg's were set up to
represent the residents and there were
often quite heated meetings between
developers residents myself I'm sure I
walked out of at least one if not two of
those meetings at times through sheer
frustration this development despite its
size was almost not going to come to
this committee there was a I thought all
big developments to actually came to
planning committee I was suddenly rang
up the planning officer who sold oh no
it doesn't have to come and I was too
late putting in my request for it to
come we then had to go around the
circle's to try and accelerate that
process I'm very grateful to councillor
Moore's council fragile II and also we
myself together implored the committee
chairmen who's not here tonight to bring
it before the committee and I am very
grateful that it has finally come so
residents can have an opportunity I
think to it just to put forward their
displeasure at a site that is clearly a
high-density site and it's not one that
we want I think the word was normal
density surely this committee is about
doing things that are better than normal
we have an opportunity to do something
while the Berlin math or a future
committee what did disturb me but during
those discussions about bringing it to
this committee I had two members of the
cabinet
tell me separately that one of the
reasons they wanted to get it through
because they are concerned about the
five-year housings
why and they were desperately keen to
get this on the books so that we
maintained a five-year housing supply I
have to say respectfully that is not a
way that a planning application of this
scale should be should have weight
behind it for such a reason many of you
are not going to be either you're not
standing again or with respect I've
probably put money on the to Peters but
beyond that I spent there's a lot of
people here who won't get elected again
a new committee will sit here a new
group of councillors and a lot of new
counselors would be with this would be a
perfect Cheney training exercise for
them all to go and understand how big
developments operate what the difference
is between an original planning
application and the reserve matters that
are coming through now and allow them to
see for themselves what is proposed on
this site so they can finally make the
decision themselves which they have to
live with it as it will come back to a
planning committee in the future when
there are condition breaches or when
conditions are going to be way through
or whether there are challenges to
what's going on they should be part of
that process and it does concern me if
there is even a perception that this
gets rushed through this evening without
giving it due consideration with a site
visit for those they're going to be
looking at it through the future there
are some issues with the density there
are issues with disability access there
are issues I know we can't deal with it
now but with the transport access and I
think it is concerning that that we're
here today trying to make a decision
eight days or nine days whatever it is
before an election some of you and again
I mean this respectfully but I just
think in my own situation as we come
towards the end of our tenure service we
may not be as focused as you might
normally be on planning applications
some of you may you know not care as
much some of you may think well you know
we've had our clashes with Audrey over
the past maybe we can you know be
spiteful and you know have a go at him
over this but remember it's the
residents you have to live with the
consequences of the decisions you make
tonight
so I'm not going to sit here with a long
list of planning reasons why you should
object this reject this all I'm saying
and I implore you please defer it and
let the new committee make that decision
in a few weeks time when they live with
the consequences thank you thank you
any questions thank you
good evening counselor Audrey I noticed
Stratford town council have no objection
to this planning application and in fact
they're quite enthusiastic about it
saying how pleased they are to see the
how the housing mix has been amended and
how it Accords with the Stratford
neighbourhood plan which has been
adopted can I ask you what sort of
liaison you have had way Stratford Town
Council and obviously if there's being
concerned and brags do you know why the
they're not here to represent elements
of Stratford happy dance that council
Perry the Town Council to be clear the
way that has worked they were I would
use the word violently opposed to it
until a meeting a private meeting a
closed meeting as I understand it with
the developers where that decision was
changed by them and then subsequently I
think it was councillor Ian fragile II
who runs that Planning Group
subsequently agreed that they would
change their position on it what was
interesting is that they weren't they
didn't inform the residents group which
i think is a shame for their reasons so
that is a bit of a dark patch for us as
to why but here tonight in the room
you've got council Wilcock and council
wall who have both would both I'm sure
if invited to and I know council will
did time request to speak but it was
turned down would both be here saying
that still from the town council
perspective they do not agree with the
Town Council's position as local town
council members so it became a wider
view
I do accept the developer I think went
to great lengths to address some of
those issues not all but some of them is
my understanding
but it was a surprise say to the
residents group who went to that meeting
to suddenly be told of the count council
had done a complete u-turn and I think
is very disappointing
and I've separately said to council cup
but I didn't say it on my comments but
actually I think it was a great shame
that they let down the residents so
badly by not working with them too and
explain to them why they may have
changed their view Thompson or organ
Thank You chair immensity in your speech
I wonder if you could tell me what the
proposed density of this development is
but it was it was up to 500 and the
developer confirmed earlier that it is
at 500 so they've gone right to the
maximum so the up to as I suspect we all
suspected in the first place was it was
a nice to have but was never going to be
implored the issue with 500 homes on
this site I mean you'll be very familiar
where it is you know is we've seen all
around Stratford these developments that
are normal density that with respect are
not places that perhaps into you and I
would want to live in and I think why
when we spend so much time talking about
the quality of developments and trying
to be proud of what we're doing in
Stratford
why do we allow these things to happen
that are normal why don't we do
something that is better than normal and
all I'm requesting today is let's put
that question to a new group of
councillors who come in perhaps with a
fresh approach and let them decide if
normal is good enough or if we want to
try and do something that's better than
normal if I can just rephrase my
question the density how many hectares
Thank You councillor for drew you were
quite clear that you want the committee
to defer this item as you know we have
to have clear playing reasons if their
purpose for either a site visit or a
deferral you said you have planning
reasons but you didn't really go into
them could you do that
give us some opportunity to understand
why we should be deferring all that
seeking insight was it Thank You
councillor Richards actually I wasn't
aware that for a deferral I think to do
a site visit I thought you could just
have a side visit but I would certainly
say the density should be a planning
reason for doing this the challenging
the design code disability access I
would have down there I would also have
cycle access we heard oh yes there's
some recycle and some cycle chaining
things but for development given where
they are on they could capilla we want
we talked a lot you and I in the past
have had debates about transport
strategy and how this would be a perfect
site to ensure that people could go
either from the site to the train
station by a cycle route or from the
from the site into town along the canal
you can't actually access the train
station at the moment despite the fact
residents requested it from day one by
cycle you have to go and queue up at
this traffic light and go over this
bridge that the canals trust have
admitted within 10 years is probably
going to collapse and we have six months
of you know a bit like for those of you
who remember the bid footbridge Peter
Barnes will remember this that bid for
bridge once something happens there for
six months you probably get it's all
closed down as everyone wonders what
they're going to do about it it is an
accident waiting to happen on that
bridge but I'm sure I'll be told not
part of this committee's decision on
this thing but there was nothing to do
on cycle so I would also say cycles
within and access to and from the
cycling side are there the other aspect
I'd also queriers again it was referred
to today as a school site it is a bit of
Greenfield that was always the contested
it should be for educational purposes
and I think this committee should still
be clarifying that it is for educational
purposes and not necessarily either a
secondary school which probably won't
now be required given the school that's
being built over on our master and you
know all the primary school site given
that within Bishop term we have an
extended primary school that's been done
very well and we're very grateful for
but educational purposes
should be clarified as part of you
visiting the site all your successors
visiting the site thank you sorry I
wrote four of those down I missed one of
them so I got a high density the
disability access cycles the educational
those one other you said forgive me I
didn't write it down quickly charges
design code that was it thank you bombs
what there is councillor Barnes is some
land set aside for we if you hark back
to the committee in 2015 I think was
David Jeffries will be very familiar
with this lot of discussions with us
over we specifically I actually
specifically requested that it wasn't
deemed of school which was put forward
as a site that could be a school that
have been put forward by the developer
and remember I think to be clear under
the 106 don't think any money is
available for this is it's just a plot
of land as I require I said no no
because we had that new primary school
in Bishop Joe northern primary school
extension can it please be for
educational purposes which was agreed
but subsequently one could debate the
rights and wrongs and who didn't fit in
which document it's always reverted back
to being a school we don't think that's
the best use of it I think it is still
ambiguous I think the county council is
too ambiguous over what its position is
on it and I think this or if I may
respectfully say a future committee
should be clear that is for educational
purposes not necessarily a school and it
could be for disabled educational
purposes you know for instance
councillor Atkinson I think your
expressions about who may be here or not
is very hypothetically you could really
have five members who are seeking
re-election coming back here I'm the
only one who is not actually five one
two three four five Chancellor jaha
neither two of us are not I I just
cannot see it but of course can what I
can't understand actually in what you're
saying is that on page 16 17 and 18
of the report there is consultation of
the wide nature Highways Authority
environmental health historic England
ecology it's extremely wide are you
saying that their opinions have to be
ignored in order to meet your request
that it is deferred is the not
sufficient experience there in
addressing this application I can't you
know really I just find your point a bit
sort of abstract Carol's a concern of
course one if there are some people
around that around the table today who
who I think quite regularly cite we
should we should ignore all expert
advice these days on another matter but
the reality is these experts I think
have a valid opinion they've expressed
their opinion
what does concern me of an application
of this size and scale cancer Atkinson
is the residence two of whom spoken
today one as an individual one
representing a group of seventy plus
individuals are not content that they
have been involved in the latest
discussions of the reserved matters and
they still feel the system is failing
them and they specifically said they
would definitely request a deferral so
they have an opportunity with those
councillors going forward who have to
live with this and ensure it's
implemented correctly agree with you
know a decision now I'm expecting at the
next planning meeting those councillors
assuming they've dumbass I visit to come
to a decision new residents if I may
speak on their behalf accept that houses
are being built on the site that's not
dispute they have come to accept that
the road access is what it is what they
want to ensure is the type of
development that's there is something
that they have had a chance to influence
those people who are substituting to
ensure it's being built that way that's
the key point we're making thank you any
more questions Thank You counsel Audrey
I'd like to invite the committee's to
ask any questions of offices councillor
Richards thank you I've quite a long
list
I may just keep going so first of all I
know we're not here to talk about the
layout of the roads and then trees and
lots of stuff but the residents did make
a very valid point about the bridge and
the potential future replacement of my
from what I can see on this map it's
with talking bottom right-hand corner of
the green area and the bridges to the
right of that so from a Highways
perspective if a new bridge was proposed
there or needed to go there
god forbid the one that has now falls
down is there enough space for it for a
new one to be placed there president the
the actual structure bridges into
controlled by the County Council it's
the canals and rivers trust if that and
I believe the current which you may have
some conservation and heritage measures
protecting it
therefore if the existing structure was
to collapse the canals and rivers to us
would have to replace that potentially
with a like structure based on its
design and make sure it meets its
heritage and conservation aspects the
County Council does have an ambition to
replace that bridge with a more modern
bridge but it also doesn't want to
provide it in terms of two-way traffic
because we open an alternative route on
Bishop tan line to the 846 so there was
a balance to be struck at the present
there was no plans to replace that
bridge only the plans for the
signalization which was approved under
the outline so that I already understand
we're talking hypothetically because if
that bridge does collapse and it needs
to be built out and there's houses in
the way ain't gonna get built in your
opinion is there sufficient area because
that's clearly a green buffer
it's a sufficient area there for a
bridge to be put in to replace at your
standards I can't say yes or no
councilor it's not really a matter that
you can consider and reserve matter
application and it would be dealt with
under the Highways Act and highways we
would look at
in terms of its design standards it
isn't a real planning argument that we
can take into consideration okay sports
facilities sports England have obviously
made their they've said no objection but
they would like through an s106 some
form of contribution towards sports
facilities have we sought that and if
not why not
so the time for agreeing the section 106
provision was an outline stage Sport
England were consulted at that moment in
time and I think there was but then
you've probably advised better there was
yeah they did raise similar sort of
issues they didn't identify a particular
project which they said should be
invested in in terms of a section 106
they didn't identify a particular in
need in the district arising from that
and the evidence base of the council at
that time didn't point us in that
direction so it wasn't secured by way of
a section 106 the recently adopted cost
strategy at that point was the starting
point for decision making and that set
out what facilities should be provided
by this development in terms of the
number of houses the amount of open
space and so on and that did not include
a requirement for an indoor play
facility or sports facility and so it
wasn't seemed justified through the
process so given it wasn't justified at
the outline stage at the reserve matters
we can't add it in its assembly on
something yeah okay back to highway
sorry I like this when I put this one
hidden away in the top end of my notes
and there was a suggestion that their
highways haven't approved the internal
road layout is that correct that's
incorrect the highway authority now
through reserve matters does a full
technical assessment of the horrid
layout to a to the section 38 process
the next stage after you give approval
is that the applicants will submit the
technical approval under Section 38 the
highways act for Road adoptions okay
thank you
now on to the there were five items
listed wag massive watery for proposal
for site visit or deferral
I wanted to very quickly discuss them
alone so the density for our benefit
what is the density per hectare please
and does it accord with our requirements
yeah I can fill you in in that respect
the overall area of the site is 25
hectares there's 500 dwellings proposed
that results in density per hectare
about 20 the reason that some of these
residential areas look quite dense is
because we haven't necessarily followed
a strictly normal approach on this what
we sought to do and what is supported by
the core strategy is deliver a
substantial area of public open space so
the development delivers around 8.9
hectares of public open space as part of
the scheme and by virtue of that there
are some denser areas of residential
that's supported by the core strategy
and the parameters plan which was
approved at the outline stage which was
presented to members I would just add to
that since the housing mix was changed
it's actually loosened the grain of the
development in places so whilst the
calculation is still going to be the
same because you've got smaller one bed
units you know in if it were all five
bed units it would look more dense than
where one bed units are proposed so
there are certain sections of the site
here for example where we've actually
increased the amount of space in
addition to what was agreed outline
stage and the same sort of this pocket
here as well okay so you're entirely
happy that 20 per hectare was slightly
tighter in some areas fits with the
agreed parameters the design code it
obviously fits with the design code as
well presumably as part of the design
code that's gone through can you explain
to me the process that has gone through
how much involvement residents had in
the residents action group have had an
input
yes certainly happy to do that the
design code was born out of a condition
members placed on the original outline
permission they sought for a design code
to address a range of issues
accompanying that condition was a
informative note that suggested that the
design code should be the subject of
liaison with a steering group the
steering group was made up of officers
of the council the applicants ward
members the residents group the Town
Council County counts officers and
county councillors were also invited as
well as I think the applicants said it
was chaired by portfolio holder for
planning Baron Pemberton we met on a
number of occasions
seven occasions throughout the year and
sought to progress a design code the
design code changed radically during
that period I think counselor Vaudrey
spoke clearly when he said that there
were some frustrations emerging out of
that and a number of those frustrations
are on display tonight that it's
principally because neither the dark
design code nor the reserved matters can
revisit the things which were determined
by the Alpine planning application
specifically the access and the matters
covered by the section 106 agreement
which were all settled in that committee
when we considered the outline
permission and members resolved to
approve the application its maintained
members result - sorry I'm talking about
design code then who who gave the final
sign-off on that design code was it a
unanimous agreement from those attending
so there wasn't a vote or anything like
that the progress of the design code
moved forward and then following a final
iteration it circulated final comments
were sought and then officers in the
coordinates with the Constitution
delegated authority discharged the
condition relating
okay sorry if I'm making tea I've got
three more if that's right the
educational purposes I think I know the
answers to this already
but could you just inform members of the
committee about that I don't think you
forms part this application anyway
because it's reserved matters but if you
could inform us of what we need to know
I think the important thing to say is
that the land is safeguarded rather than
proposed to be a primary school the the
land itself was identified through the
process of the application by the
education authority as language what
they may need to meet education purposes
I think initially that was expected to
be a primary school and that is the
basis upon which they made a demand they
sought for the local planning authority
through section 106 to secure that land
so that they might deliver an education
facility on it the justification for
that is borne out of their assessment of
what likely need is going to be rated by
this site and other sites in the
district and the section 106 provides an
opportunity for them to take that land
off the developer and deliver an
education facility on it and if they
don't do that within a period then the
land would effectively return to the
applicant who may subsequently make
applications for alternative uses on it
so ultimately its safeguarded for
educational purposes for a period and it
then 8.now falls on the County Council
to ensure they demonstrate the need and
then then they can take delivery of that
land before delivering the specific
provisions of the section 106 and the
criteria against which the council
County Council can claim that land and
retain it we're agreed by the County
Council and the last two things on my
list I'll do them at the same time the
disability access and cycles and access
recycles turn from the site to and from
so the disability access from my
understanding of the discussion related
to the bridge which is outside of the
application site I believe that this
would be a matter that would have been
considered an outline stage there is
also signalization of that bridge which
is something that isn't in place at this
moment in time and has been agreed as
part of the outline consent so that
should improve access across the bridge
and then in relation to cycle provisions
before you go onto cycles the get to the
disability access the rest of the site
is also vital as well because there may
well be people who require that access
to the properties were then we can cover
that as well yes so when the Highway
Authority undertakes its review of the
site layout and the road loud we have to
make sure it's compliant with your
qualities up to 2010 and DDA compliant
so the officers at the county have done
that assessment in terms of driveways
the pedestrian foot ways and the
connections but also on the bridge there
is a set pedestrian stage that includes
for pedestrians just to cross over that
bridge without any vehicle of traffic on
the bridge as well within the site is
all part of DDA compliant Equality Act
yeah in addition I think it's probably
worth saying that a number of the
properties are m42 building regs
compliant which is that they are
designed to be adaptable for disabled
people's in the future
it was required I think was 50% of the
properties had to achieve that yeah so
obviously access was agreed at outline
stage so we are limited in the
consideration of this application to the
internal road layout the design code
sought to ensure that there would be
paths throughout the site to enable
anybody to walk cycle through the site
and get to those access points and
certainly in considering this
application those paths have been
considered the parameter blocks also
better enable anybody who's perhaps on a
bike to quite quickly get from their
block on do one of the pathway to the
site and then out onto the
extended network in addition outline
stage for under one of the section 106
agreements there's both a road safety
contribution for 50,000 pounds it was
agreed and there was also play with
improvements to be certainly to the
canal network Canal towpath and cycling
contributions which amounted to sizeable
song together so what you're saying I
mean it'd be helpful if you could
demonstrate on that plan where the roots
are that people can get to and from
where they need to get from but you're
saying that cycles can in fact access
the towpath to the canal they can access
cycles provision to each of the exits
and then through into bishops and then
from the internal node of the plan so
this is the connections plan that I've
just displayed now the canal is clearly
in the way so you have to exit the site
over the bridge to get on to the Canal
towpath and that will set our outline
stage but that is an option available
and then that all you can exit there
from the many exits that have been
accesses that have been approved onto
the main road layout but noticeably you
can be done in the site go along one of
the numerous parts of the purple path
shown there or the blue path at the end
get from the housing or you know housing
outside onto the site into those through
the site to whether the play area onto
the cycle network or footpath and the
red arrows on there demonstrate exits
that forth that's not the right put
pedestrians and cyclists from the site
yes would you just be able to explain
the color coding there because I can't
read that writing down the side and just
an hour and we still don't seem to come
to a conclusion for the cyclists that
the airline stage was wrong I'll let you
ask a question I mean if you've got one
let me just have this clarified I
probably can't read it either
no from memory the the purple paths are
hogging paths so they're designed to be
that you could absolutely walk along
them or cycle on the but not at speed
they're not designed to be proper cycle
track but certainly if you are a parent
with a child on a buggy with a buggy or
on their bike or scooter you would be
able to get across those and certainly
you would slowly cycle across them if
you were Keynes like in thews East the
darker purple path at the bottom is I
think it's slightly wider yeah path to
the site and then the yellow dotted
lines are the main road network through
the site and what's wrong that does the
main road network have capacity for
pedestrian and cycle use yes it does
because as part of the outline as well
we commute we've got a section 26 to
change the speed limits to bring it down
to a 30 mile per hour speed limit and
that was a long bishops inlay and
extending out of the Ridgeway and that
enables and then some of the funds was
to connect to the railway station at
Stratford Parkway yes on that specific
point what if you're on bike how you how
will you get to Parkway what's the best
in easiest way and how is that going to
be improved to build for people to go to
do that from this site so it's so it's
to use the internal bot cycle routes
that are within the site and come out as
close as you can to the canal bridge or
along the route you'll go over the canal
bridge using signal stage and then we've
got monies to do a scheme to improve
access route to the railway station and
because you know there's another site
opposite of our weigh station as well
we're looking to try improve access as
well to start the Parkway councillor
Barnes interrupting and we had this
discussion before on mother was going to
be trapezoids for cars and both and
separately for cyclists
Sartre way under the bridge asked me
four foot six high otherwise you can't
get onto the bridge on the cycleway
and they didn't know whether you've got
to cross the road to get on the canal
because the circle was on the other side
of the road we were expecting some sort
of more permanent or better explained or
I can't fully understand what exactly is
going on
we can't lower the bridge because
charity count suppose if you could just
help me
it's a request Jim because remember this
is questions to officer station if I was
going to wound code or to the railway
station and I was coming over the bridge
the new bridge you would use the
internal path network within the site to
enter Bishop turn lane as close to the
existing canal bridge as you could the
existing canal bridge will be signalized
so it will have a pedestrian phase
you'll wait your pedestrian phase and
safely maneuver onto the Canal towpath
on bishops and Lane and travel to Rome
code that way all of that lies outside
of the application which we are
considering today the pedestrianisation
of that bridge the nature of the bridge
is only the internal paths which are
under consideration as part of this
reserve matters any of this counts a
parry
thank you chair I just wonder whether I
could have some clarification on when
the request from Stratford town council
came forward to speak at committee on
this planning application if they did
indeed do so
though they haven't asked to speak at
this planning committee counts of
fielding a question you explained the
bus turning circle within the within the
site does it go along some of these
roads or does it or just turn around at
the roundabout by the play area
sorry school so but bus was agreed
through the site at outline stage if you
can see my cursor here this is where the
bus would enter it would come through
this road and it would come out at the
roundabout and there is a bus stop
proposed around about here it then
travels along the bishop turn road and
there's an existing but bishop turn lane
and there's an existing bus stop there I
think the frequency of the buses was
also increased at outlined stage as well
I just like to ask as I raised with the
applicant I'm sometimes a bit concern
that the public open space is it's open
but it's slightly featureless and it
becomes almost a bit sort of dead
looking and inactive from a green
perspective I'm just wondering from the
landscaping plan what elements if any
there are to it to address that issue so
it's always very very difficult to
present landscaping plans a planning
committee there's I think there's sort
of 1012 of them they all overlap each
other to try to show that the the level
of detail that's proposed and they have
been robustly assessed by our landscape
officer unamended throughout this
application process if you can see on
this section here there's areas of more
dense planting those are proposed as
trees within that public open space area
then there's areas of sort of more
natural meadow grass that's proposed and
the management plan will cover how
frequently those areas
cut so that you have some areas that is
sort of more natural and some that a
more formal way you perhaps could
informally kick a football about or
whatever sport you may wish to partake
in certainly the attenuation basins have
been landscaped that's been something
that we you know we were all keen to
ensure happens and they are to be
planted with sort of meadow flowers on
the edging the size of trees and density
of trees has been amended throughout the
application process to ensure that we're
initially quite a few trees
what proposed while still a significant
amount of trees are proposed there's
been a change to sort of larger trees so
that they can establish quicker within
within sort of certainly these areas and
then obviously there's the retention of
the protected trees to the front and a
large section of the of the hedging
albeit that would be managed going
forward thank you any other questions
if I could open it up to debate
Chancellor Perry as everybody seems to
be a bit quiet on this one I'll come
straight in first of all I think it's
it's always good to hear that there's
been some good engagement between the
developers and the steering committee
was set up and they obviously went
through all the design codes and you
know there has been quite a lot of
collaboration it would appear to me
particularly in my experience of larger
developments where we haven't had that
sort of level of of involvement picking
up on council of orders point of view in
terms that he feels it should be
deferred until the new council is is
formed
obviously none of us know those who are
standing don't know whether they'll be
in but all I can say is that at least
the committee this evening we bring
depth of experience of planning matters
we've been through the core strategy for
my part I also sit on planning East so I
do two planning committees you know we
have all been involved in very
large-scale
themes and if the committee's going
forward again to have a lot of new faces
you know they will not have the depth of
experience that collectively we have
this evening so from that point of view
I certainly wouldn't be in favor of
deferring because I think the expertise
we have this evening you know is a
first-class top-level my other query
would be in terms of deferring would be
you know the the elements that have been
put forward to us this evening it's you
know there are a lot of Givens that you
know the design codes been through
we have in the proposal that Stratford
Town Council is is happy with what's
been put forward it confines to
Stratford neighbourhood plan now it's
it's unfortunate as council of Audrey
mentioned that Stratford town council
are not here but they they obviously
were very happy because they didn't they
must have known about the agenda all
certainly there were board members and
other members they must have known about
it so they're not here this evening so
on the basis of the information that I
have in front of me on a proposal and
having listened very carefully to all
sides I will be going with the officers
recommendation councillor Richards
we've been extraordinarily flower I
think this committee tonight in
exploring a number of the details and
whilst to a large the extent I agree
with what kinds of Perry said in terms
of the involvement that the council have
had stakeholders have had and the
applicants have had to get this to where
it is evidently there are still some
concerns that have been expressed by
residents tonight we have a duty to make
sure that we address as many of those as
we possibly can in appropriate manner
before we finally make our decisions as
a group tonight we've sought to explore
the issues that have been put forward
and if I just very quickly revisit some
of them so for a deferral or a or a site
visit the reasons that we've considered
have been the density what we've been
told very clearly the density it meets
the 500 that limits that were set both
by our core strategy and by the outline
planning application within that we're
looking at 20 home
site which fits a game within the design
code and within our core strategy so
from a density point of view I can't see
that that really is a solid reason to
either defer or to request a site visit
the disability accesses again has been
discussed at length within the site it
has to meet the criteria equalities Act
which we're told it does externally
however I there are concerns but that's
not a decision that we're able to make
tonight because it's not part of this
application so whilst it's a frustration
and I remember sitting on the original
outline application that we had a
frustration again with that bridge
tallington and perhaps our hands are
tied because it's not doesn't make up
part of this application is a real
frustration with the planning process
but that is planning law the educational
side of things we've dealt with I'm
pretty satisfied that that has been
enshrined within the 106 and is in fact
safeguarded the sports facilities we've
spoken about layout scale process we've
spoken about the design code it's been
through a thorough process and again
whilst there are residents who are not
happy with it
it has been through an extensive process
not a process that we've been a party to
unfortunately but it has been to an
extensive process and we're told by our
by our officers that this does fit
within that design code so again it's
not as not a vibe recent we're defer or
secret site visit the only thing that we
have an issue with and councillor Barnes
as an avid cyclist would understand
cycle routes I'm sure even he is saying
tonight he's find it confusing and
difficult to understand that as the only
thing I can see that could potentially
cause an issue in determining this I'm
not sure if it's a strong enough reason
to suggest either we go for a site visit
to fully understand the routes and the
routing or even defer until we get more
information I hope not that to debate by
the committee but that's where I stand
at the moment that
the only thing I can see that could
potentially have any form of weight when
it comes to considering either a
determine or site visit yeah I think
I'll leave it at that and I'll probably
come back again in a minute when we've
had a bit more debate before I come to
counts Laban's I'll I'll just say
something I actually really understand
why residents who live here feel so
strongly about this application and I
suspect it partly goes back to the
manner in which it was inserted into the
core strategy which I felt was very
unfortunate because it was something
that came along at the last minute I
don't feel residents at the time had
very much opportunity to gather
themselves in order to put forward
proper objection and consider the the
the extensiveness of this or not and my
heart goes out to people frankly who
obviously chose to live here for a
certain reason and it was because
there's a sense of openness and it was a
sense of being on the edge of town and
all of a sudden people who live there in
the space of a very short period of time
find themselves actually some widget
within let's face it an extremely large
development so I entirely understand why
people are so frustrated am i entirely
understand as well why it then comes to
the point of reserved matters and
actually it feels as though the ability
to influence and control what it looks
like is relatively limited all I would
like to do is reassure people but
actually this committee does think very
carefully about actually is this
appropriate and and and is it a good
site and is it the best that we can try
to achieve in terms of what's there I
understand the concerns about density
but what I would observe is for example
there is the possibility of spreading
those houses out but the you know the
trade-off for that is you lose some of
the open space and the openness and in
terms of trying to create something
which is less more pleasant to live in
that is difficult and there is the other
reality in the balance which is we have
to
sensibly managing news land there are
only so many sites available to us to
build the housing that we are required
to build nationally we don't have a
choice with housing numbers we're told
we must find somewhere for them to be
and so clearly if you put fewer houses
here you have to allocate another site
it's difficult it's not an easy balance
to strike that's not to say don't
sympathize with the people who live
close to this my feeling is actually I'm
sure it hasn't met all of residence
requirements in terms of the
consultation and the process but it is a
more thorough process than is often the
case I know that not every site will
have its own particular design code for
the particular area it will be more
generic principles there certainly isn't
a steering group process for the vast
majority of sites and so whilst that
might not have gained everything for
residents I'm hoping particularly with
the Town Council's influence I
understand some modifications have been
made to that site and it is better I I
also want to reassure people that from
my perspective if I thought they were
very substantial amendments that needed
to be made here for me whatever the
issues about the five-year housing land
supply it wouldn't be the main
consideration it would be about getting
this right but I have to agree with
councillor Richards when we look at the
detail of what what we you know what are
the objections the reality is we are
mainly told now on design that it's
acceptable and actually is is in many
ways it's attractive and it has that
level of detail which takes it above
essentially Lego houses as I have
sometimes said there has been a lot of
thought given to the landscaping no it's
been before the landscaping officer
twice and I've been anxious to ask about
whether that's happened and certainly
the landscaping officers asked for
amendments and they've been incorporated
and there seems to have been given some
thought about the balance there I was
anxious to make sure that the issues
that have been raised by residents today
were properly explored and I have to say
they have the answers I've been given by
officers particularly but also applicant
have put my mind at rest on some of
those things particularly
have to say about cycle axes I have to
disagree slightly with councilor riches
I actually like the fact here that we've
got a cycle path that actually is usable
around the edge of the site because
obviously one of the issues for cyclists
ISM coming into conflict with traffic
down Main Roads whereas here we've got
the opportunity for people to use that
around the edge of site to cycle and
enter and exit the site so it would seem
to me actually that compared to some of
the applications we've seen more thought
has actually been given to that that
issue of connectivity and how people can
actually get out onto network and I'm
also I am pleased to hear that there is
provision made through the section 106
for improvements a cycle networks into
town so whilst I'm sure from many
people's perspective it's not perfect
I'm relatively satisfied that this meets
the requirements in terms of what sets
out and what I certainly don't think is
that there are any significant or
substantial planning reasons that we
could practically that we could possibly
refuse it on that there aren't just
those major things which are glaring out
so I have to say I would I'd propose
granting this application but I'm very
keen to hear from any other member of
the committee so councillor Barnes
[Music]
different parties been involved the
concern of the outline was the new
bridge or the replacement bridge the
cycleway both ways as far as I'm
concerned that has not been addressed it
was a number of people from warm coat
said everybody from the site will be
going through that way to Birmingham
which may or may not be right but as a
reason for refusal I don't think was old
we have had meetings with British
waterways and know the rules she's going
to be extremely difficult even if they
can build a bridge there because of the
right-of-way the 4.6 so
those are my few words Annalise wants to
say anything I don't know councillor
fielding all I can say is that I've
never known a large application where
there haven't been a lot of objections
we have to make a decision on what we
have before us and I agree with what is
being said that it's unfortunate
planning application would anybody wish
to second my proposal I'm afraid you
can't I would love to be able to take a
question for me but we there is a
process we have to follow in it has to
be so that there's fair responses so we
have to we have to do it that way I'm
afraid I know I'm sorry I I'm not
allowed to do that within the structure
of the the way the committee operates
particularly now we finished debate okay
the issue isn't about time and not
wanting to hear you the issue is about
it being a fair process so you've had
your opportunity and then there is the
that people need to be able to respond
to that then ask questions of officers
so what I'm very conscious of is if new
issues are raised I don't want to have
to get a whole load of other people in
order to respond to it so if you
wouldn't mind and I do I'm sorry but I
will have to draw a line there and ask
people to vote on the proposals it's
just been put okay okay committee
members the proposal before us is to
grant application 1801 o61 all those in
favor
okay six chairman all those against any
abstention one German thank you this
committee was officer Graham the
application will have a three minute
break
we are resumed committee now intends to
deal with the next three applications
and we will take them together so what I
propose to do is the objectors I will
deal with as follows mr. Thompson will
be given six minutes because he would
have had three minutes on each
application and mr. McDonald three
minutes as he was objecting in relation
to one of the applications the applicant
agent will have 9 minutes in total and
counselor off role 15 but obviously are
not obliged to use all of your time so
if we firstly turn to officer
presentation thank you Thank You
chairman I was just stated I'll be
presenting three reserved matters
together all of these pursuant to
outline application reference 14 double
O 2 62 out and they are all located but
the outline is located at odd and he'd
farm as indicated by the black dot this
slide shows the red line for the entire
outline application site the reserved
matters applications each make up a
parcel with in that outline site I will
deal with each application in turn in
this presentation the reason for
presenting them collectively is because
obviously they all relate to the same
outline application and there was a
commitment at previous committees to
bring these applications to you
comprehensively this is a satellite
image or aerial image of the site for
context purposes just to identify the
site so this is odd and Heath farm to
the north of the site is the
stratford-upon-avon golf club the LOX
dealer Locksley Road bisects the site
access was agreed at outline stage for
this application as were a raft of
contributions through a section 106
agreement and 28 conditions none of
these conditions specifically required
any information to be submitted at
reserve matters
stage albeit some of them have informed
the reserve masters details but we are
specifically here looking at the reserve
matters of appearance landscaping layout
and scale at outline stage a parameters
plan was agreed this had an indicative
layout shown on it showing areas where
there should be buffer zones around the
site where the public open space should
be and where housing could be this plan
is the parameters plan or the zoning
plan approved for the site outline stage
the dark green areas are the buffer
zones around the perimeter of the site
the lighter green areas are the public
open space it's important to
differentiate that the buffer zones are
not intended to be public open space
then we have the sort of the two brown
shades this is where housing is
permitted and there are Heights set
within that within the condition of the
outline consent as with any large
planning application it's quite common
to have a phasing condition imposed and
outline stage it was required that this
was submitted prior to the submission of
any reserved matters application and I'm
hoping that this starts to demonstrate
why we're looking at all three together
and where we are where we are
so the phasing with the first developer
to come to the table effectively were
Taylor Wimpey and they had were looking
at what's the red zone of this site so
phase two housing development phase one
was drainage which is the hatched area
and that's not before you
the sorry that the purple area that the
hatched area is then the green
infrastructure area so as effectively
that's seen as the landscaping that's
outside of anybody's actual individual
plot ownership and it includes the
buffer zones and the public open space
and Taylor Wimpey submitted both phase
two for their housing and phase three
the green infrastructure together and
that at the time of the phasing plan and
the time of that submission it was not
known who the who the future developers
would be or if there would be a future
application when phase two and three
were presented to you first and the
application by spitfyre had just been
made and there was concern about the
difference between the two developers as
well as concern over the quality of the
application that had been submitted by
Taylor Wimpey it so there was a
commitment at that point in time all
three applications would come before you
and we looked at comprehensively
following on from even leading up to
that committee but for following on from
that committee a working group has very
much been established it's an informal
arrangement it involves local members of
ward councillor myself and developed
both sets of developers they've looked
at the issues that were raised at the
previous committee they've looked at the
new scheme that has been proposed for
Spitfire and they've looked at the
landscaping of the the scheme
comprehensively so now turning to phase
2 which is the Taylor Wimpey scheme on
item 5 on your agenda this light was
previously presented to you at Planning
Committee and has been significantly
changed since then so these green blobs
on the plan are my annotation just to
try to highlight the areas of the of
this scheme that has been most
significantly changed since it was
previously presented to you
the developers have significantly
changed housing mixed although that
wasn't a condition on the outline they
have changed the housing mix to accord
with the NDP and they have changed
housing type significantly so that there
are lots more one bed units on the site
this has had a consequence of changing
house type and loosening the grain of
the development particularly around here
they've also included more bungalows on
the site which is what's shown here
there's been reorientation of properties
though these where they were sort of
terraced coming down here these now face
on to this main spine road frontage and
then in addition to those alterations
there have been elevational changes to
the proposed house types again it's
really hard to show street scene
elevations but this is just a flavor of
the Taylor Wimpey house type but going
into more specific detail this is one of
the proposed house types this is part of
a terrace row so how its depicted is for
each individual property promisee
they're put together and there'd be a
gable end to the frontage and then
there's been introduction of additional
detailing such as tax windows to the
side of properties to try to create more
architectural features where you may
otherwise see a blank wall this is one
of the new housing types that's being
proposed within the scheme so I've shown
that the front that appears as a
semi-detached pair but is actually four
flats across the site with again tax
windows in the side elevation and as a
result of the change in housing mix and
also considered to be an architectural
detailing through the site this is one
of the more prominent corner properties
on the site so showing that there's
active frontage due to the main frontage
but also by the tax window and a bay
window on the side elevation and this is
just an illustration of one of the
bungalows it's now proposed so now
moving on to the green infrastructure
which is item six or
agenda again it's very difficult to show
how landscape landscaping in detail each
of these boxes shown on this plan is an
individual plan that sets out density
species type of planting across the site
this has been amended since it was last
presented to you including different
species particularly in the buffer zones
as a result of consultation through the
working group to include species that
are included in the secured by design
mix that the police advocate the green
infrastructure also details the two
areas of play space across the site one
is to the south of the Taylor Wimpey
scheme and one is to the north of the
proposed spitfyre scheme and both
contain a mixture of types of equipment
and ancillary details such as bins and
benches and there are cycle racks also
this is the other plate area and then
finally turning two phases four and five
this is a Spitfire scheme this hasn't
previously been presented to you but has
nonetheless gone through the same
working group process and has been
amended significantly since it was
originally submitted this has included
the setting back of housing on the
frontage here from the Loxley Road where
previously that was further forward with
a parking courtyard to the back it's
resulted in changes the elevational
treatment and roof detailing this parcel
here has been changed quite
significantly with now apartments being
proposed here to try to create both the
mix and space around the site there's
been reallocation of a number of units
including a flat over garage from here
to over here because it was felt that
that created a better mix and a better
appearance across the site again this is
just an illustrative
street scene is quite hard to read in
it's flat version I have a visual age
which hopefully will help in a moment
look at the the site more
comprehensively but just as an
indication of detail this is the more
contemporary style of Spitfire this is
one of the flaps so although that
appears to be a single unit you've got a
ground floor flat on the first floor
flat this is on the Loxley road frontage
and if you can see the bottom image
you'll notice that it's actually two
sets of semi-detached pairs that the the
ambition has been to achieve what like
larger detached properties which would
be more characteristic on the rocks
erode the context these are all houses
that are found on the rocks erode there
is a mixture of more traditional
properties
there's definitely render detailing
there's brick detailing there's
different colors and styles and a real
mix down there comprehensively this is
the entirety of the scheme so this is
the layout including all of the houses
for both elements of the site
connections and connectivity was a
matter that came up previously through
the site and much like the previous
application access into and out of the
site was agreed outline stage so we are
just looking at the internal road layout
provisions were made for funds to go
towards improvements of public open
public rights-of-way at outline stage
and the like so this is purely looking
at how you could travel through the site
into the wider area including to the
north would be a school there has been
an improvement of the width of the road
on one side of the pavement to ensure
that you could walk with a buggy or you
know something similar through through
the site leading quite specifically to
destination of play area here
and again to the south of the site and
then there are dedicated tracks through
here this northern parcel here as shown
at the parameters plan stage is public
open space was agreed as public open
space this area here there's but it
shown as a potential destination however
it's just planted so yes you could
perhaps go and have a picnic or
what-have-you there but there's
certainly no footpaths in that location
and there's no public place space
proposed in that particular location the
attenuations basin is to the very top of
the site here and then I have a video
which is fundamentally a it's a useful
tool it's it kind of shows that the site
in its entirety I'll just talk over it
we start on the Taylor Wimpey SAR part
of the site looking from the public open
space or the play area is going into the
site the Sun goes down into the main spy
mode this is looking at the Loxy road
frontage
gained into the main spying area of the
site that the wider road to the one side
main fronted no looking on to the public
open space again there this is an
internal road it's which should be noted
there's actually more shrubbery proposed
on there it just hasn't been input onto
this video became one of the smaller
side roads
main spy mode
these are the apartments in in the
corner here
so we have the this is Locksley Road so
we have both parts of the development
briefly shown here and this then goes
back into the Taylor Wimpey part of the
site going back to their public open
space will then move on to a Spitfire
we're good halfway through the video now
see so yep this is now the Spitfire
scheme it's a central island in the site
[Music]
these are the properties that would face
onto the main public open space to the
north of the site
came from the public open space
this just it's got Spitfire and Taylor
Wimpey just to demonstrate that that's
both parts of the site so just as unreal
in terms of the recommendation item five
on your agenda which is the Taylor
Wimpey application the recommendation is
subject is to approve subject to the
completion of a legal agreement to
secure changes to the section 106 agree
to outline to ensure the provision of
the place based in relation to how the
application has now been submitted in in
phases and subject to conditions and
notes
item six which is the green
infrastructure phase or the
recommendation is to approve subject to
conditions item seven which is the
Spitfire scheme similar to the Taylor
Wimpey scheme is subject to a section
106 that is to approve search into a
subject to a section 106 and to secure
changes in relation to the provision of
the play space and subject to conditions
and notes there is an update on all
three of the applications which is in
your update sheet thank you if I could
now call upon her yes I'm sorry madam
chair I've just I do wish to disclose
something of interest particularly for
the application eighteen forward slash
zero three four five five why notices
there's an objection from
stratford-on-avon golf club I am an
associate member of stratford-on-avon
golf club my husband is a very active
member so I will sit down from the
committee at that particular point if
that's if that's been voted on as a
separate element perhaps officers can
give me advice on that but I think it
would be appropriate not to take part in
that particular aspect of this
application
polish is it was only until it turned
over the paper and saw the objection the
they'll be separate votes on all of
these and the golf club objection
relates to the Spitfire proposal I think
so if it's up to you to decide whether
you feel you've got a conflict of
interest but if you do I think it would
be appropriate for me not to take part
in that particular section of the
application okay I do believe we call it
so all right thank you
so if I could now ask mr. Thompson you
have up to six minutes from when you
start speaking thank you if I may I'd
like to set up a brief chronology to the
committee in early December last year an
application came to the committee from
Taylor Wimpey for 135 dwellings which
the wider site
about my conservative invincibility
dwelling as a working group we have
significant concerns relating to that
application which chiefly pertain to the
poor design of the scheme that is that
that city was proposed and the poor
quality of the materials that were put
forward by the applicant that
application was subsequently refused and
the applicants together with Spitfire
homes and planning offices of Victoria
were asked to engage with and work
closely with the working group and more
member the aim of this engagement was to
seek to collectively produce a better
planning application I'm pleased to say
that both developers claim listen to
what was said at this committee and
we've had a series of meetings with the
developers in the planning officer which
is delivered a series of significant
changes to both the planning
applications we've had the ability to
review draft plans and lay out through
the developers and give detailed
feedback on all matters relating to type
and quality of the proposed materials to
the detail of what type of planting will
be utilized within the landscape of the
zone surrounding the site a particular
note that's been the way both developers
have listened to a lot of concerns as a
group and though does the walk member
and they've made further changes to
their plans a good example of this is
where Taylor Wimpey of reviewed their
labs that's in the bottom left of the
screen on land adjacent to walk enclose
and have changed all of those dwellings
in this location to single storey
bungalows from the previously proposed
two-story dwellings this is a good
outcome for residents in warm clothes
you will back mountain
it's also worth noting that Taylor
Wimpey in responding to our concerns as
a working group have reduced the overall
density of their proposals to seek to
loosen up the parcel of the proposed
dwellings to the rear of the existing
house alot C roads just to the right of
that on the application to the sample
another good example of good engagement
between the parties is where Spitfire
bespoke owns and listen to the concerns
that were raised regarding the character
of Locksley Road and the proposals for a
parking cool which we have significant
concerns over our point is a group was
that the character of Roxy road is one
of dwellings set back significantly from
the road and also that a parking court
in this location was far too urban in
nature the developer listened to these
concerns and redesigned a large part of
their proposals on the northern field to
address these issues at this point I
would also like to thank you planning
officer Victoria for our hard work and
determination in providing a good
sounding board for the working group and
also acting as an effective conduit
between ourselves the amount of time
that the tourists spent with both of
ourselves and separate meetings and in
larger meetings with the developers has
been very helpful in arriving at the
schemes you have before you tonight by
approving these schemes before you it
will bring it out into a considerable
period of uncertainty for local
residents by keeping clarity as to what
is likely to be built and went thank you
thank you any questions councillors
No thank you thank you very much mr.
Thompson if I could now call mr.
McDonald mr. McDonald just so we clear I
understand that your objection relates
to the spitfire homes matter the zero
three four five five and you have three
minutes thank you yes I speak on behalf
of stratford-on-avon golf club the
purpose of condition 28 as stated by the
planning inspector at the outline
painting stage is to safeguard the
public from potential harm from stray
golf balls from the adjacent golf course
it reads full details of the level and
means of management of public access to
the area identified as open space should
be submitted one of the definitions of
management is the process of controlling
things or people so the planning respect
to require the developers to give full
details of the means by which they
control the public access to the open
space in order to ensure the public are
not hit by stray golf balls the plan
allows 50 or 60 metres between the site
boundary and the edge of the residential
development if you add 29 metres of the
golf course to the centreline of the
fairway and the green this should keep
golf balls from harming the houses and
their occupants our concern is with the
public who can still freely use the open
space between the site boundary and the
development if it's not fenced off in
the area golf balls may fall at present
families can picnic their children can
enjoy filing golf balls there they can
even stand on the boundary and watch the
golfers play we know from electronic
tracking devices that golf balls reach a
height of up to 110 feet far higher than
the
you're 60 feet of the trees on the
boundary gulfport are hard so those that
do reach the air will be falling like a
stone from a hundred foot or so hitting
a child could be fatal to meet the
requirements of condition twenty-eight
public access to the area in which they
mail and we submit must be controlled so
no one is harmed the only answer is a
cordon sanitaire a cordoned off area
free from children dog walkers and
picnickers there is a precedent for this
the appeal of planning inspector in the
open gardeners development required a
cordon sanitaire unfortunately in that
case not large enough we know from that
development despite all the fencing and
the tree planting by the golf club and
the best efforts of golfers wolves duel
and from time to time in that area up to
80 metres from the centerline of the
fairway so we urge members of the
committee please to ensure they do not
knowingly put members of the public at
risk
otherwise we submit condition 28 will be
breached
please do not risk a life for the sake
of a fence a hedge in front of the
fencing would replace hopefully they are
hedging lost along into the I thank you
committee questions it counts the bonds
do I assume that the golf course is a
bit above the green yes yeah councillor
Richards thank you for that just one
player where exactly are you proposing
this fence and at what height is this
fun is going to be it would be the one
in Elkin gardens is about two meters
high and it's just really to make sure
people can't get through to us bond to
the area where the golf balls may fall
so on that map we're talking there's
trees down yes if you if you can see I
think there's a union just you're really
close that little white that you need
from that down that's right so sort of
that area there would just need to be
all things and stuff
and stuff yes Thank You counselor
fielding a better illustration of the
golf course they're teeing off if you go
right to your left as far as you can go
let's let's start the other end where
that arrow is now is where the green is
so what they're trying to do is to hit a
ball onto that green unfortunately one
of the main errant shots is a slice
which is a high shot which goes to the
right they don't intend it both balls
cost about three pounds each so they're
certainly not expecting to do it but
unfortunately a small proportion of
balls in a year will go into that that
area and unfortunately as we know from
Elgin Gardens
it can cause not only harm but also just
great discomfort people worry about it
if they go there and they happen to you
know have a gold bullet on a picnic and
suddenly a golf ball lands you know in
the middle of the picnicking area near a
child that goes from there it's a
relatively straight hole coming from
your left it's 400 yards long and it's a
second shot which they're hitting into
the green or in some cases it'll be a
third shot but most people will be a
second shot and they're hitting the ball
about anything from 180 to 200 yards
maybe a little less if they're a really
good golfer but because all the golf
balls when they hit properly go high and
then hopefully land softly onto a green
but not softly if they're onto a person
building yeah would it be possible or
maybe I should ask the officer to plant
it as a sort of a woodland area with
trees high enough to protect people
those are all sort of questions I think
I prefer for the officers I think the
issues been raised and I think perhaps
if if there are questions about what we
do about it they might be better
addressed to the officer or the
applicant councillor Barnes I don't
quite understand the question it's just
this particular the third hole yes thank
you thank you very much mr. McDonough
thank you Thanks I could invite miss
Clark thank you you have up to nine
minutes from when you speak thank you
thank you too I am hopefully you won't
need anywhere near nine minutes and
Victoria did a fabulous job presenting
the scheme and Jonathan's done a
fabulous job doing my job for me as well
but I will go through what I need to say
is so since Planning Committee in
January a considerable amount of
additional work has been undertaken
involving a critical review of the
design and layout of the site but more
specifically the opportunity to look at
the development of the site as a whole
and as you've heard the working group
have continued to meet tell UMP and
Spitfire have been able to explain the
design rationale for the proposals more
effectively and the working group have
had an input into the discussions on
quality and landscaping which I
we have been extremely productive the
working group including cancer alphas
both local resident and ward member have
also separately considered the Spitfire
phases four and five which in new to
committee today and raised a number of
more detailed layout and design points
and I'm happy to know that the the group
consider that both developers have
listened to the concerns raised and
taken appropriate action I am happy to
rattle through the negotiated
alterations but I think I think those
have been brought to your attention
already during this time we've also
presented our results to the results of
our collaborative working to the Town
Council who have welcomed the
improvements made and raised no
objection to the proposals before you
this evening the fly through animation
has been prepared for members also
illustrates the scale appearance and
general layout of the proposals
highlighting the different characters
owns the focal buildings the corner
turning plots the central nodal point on
the northern site and both the interest
and variety that's been presented longer
the Loxley road frontage it highlights
features such as hip roofs to allow view
through the development gable and bade
detail chimney is used to Flemish brick
burned etc and demonstrates how the the
tree-lined primary access routes lead
into the lower order roads within the
site it's also important to stress that
the wider landscaping strategy seeks to
provide not only an appropriate setting
for the development but it does
incorporate defensive planting to limit
opportunities for inappropriate activity
the proposed four-way network when taken
together with the extent of the proposed
psychopathy also provides good levels of
connectivity through the phases of
development again as I know you're aware
the layout and design of the site are
matters that were reserved at the
outline application when it was
considered by an inspector at public
inquiry the resultant proposals are
bound by the parameters plan which
defines the parcels of land for
development and there are a number of
safeguarding conditions
it's important to reiterate that one of
those conditions imposed at the inquiry
stage required a management plan for the
area of open space adjacent to the golf
course and I can confirm that the
developers are working on a plan which
is likely to include for example signage
and the details of this map plan will be
presented to offices in due course for
formal discharge but it is not a matter
that is before committee for decision
today in summary my trust members will
agree that having the site presented in
its entirety reflects the outcomes of a
strong working relationship between all
parties and it is our intention that
this relationship continues through the
course of the construction of the site
and beyond to enable any issues that may
arise to be dealt with expediently and
it is on it on this basis that members
of this very experienced planning
committee adopt the officers
recommendation and move to approve thank
you very much thank you I have one
question I know quite a lot of local
concern has been raised about the
netting of hedgerows in advance of this
application could you please explain the
rationale for that and and some question
has been raised about whether that's
permitted in lawful if you could just do
with that the netting is is in order to
meet with the requirements of the
habitat regulations which is the netting
is is lawful in as much that it is a
requirement to stop nesting birds in
advance of their head hedgerow being
removed it is common practice and I
accept the that it's not necessarily the
most appropriate way of doing so but at
the moment that is that is what is
required by the ecologist for this
particular site for their hedgerow so
just so I understand it is my
understanding the rationale is because
there is an anticipation the hedgerow is
going to be removed imminently it's to
stop bird's nest
in advance of that removal that's
correct so when is it when is it thought
that that hedgerow is going to be
removed is in this application is
granted tonight when is it thought that
hedgerow is going to be removed in order
for building work to start the hedgerow
will need to be removed in order to do
the works to the road the section 2 7 8
works which involve widening the road
and then the new petrol is planted at
the back of that new footpath so the in
order to comply with the habitat
regulations the netting is done in the
event that any work smites occur during
the planting season so it's a
safeguarding that were obliged to do I
suppose is it likely that works are
going to start in in that in that
nesting season it's possible yes which
is why it's being done right ok
any other questions councillor fielding
you're putting in there there will be
areas for the disabled specifically yes
yes I believe that is a condition on the
application about electricity charging
points yes that would apply to all
vehicles are you putting traffic calming
situations within the roads there is
part of the outline application secured
a sent a sort of central crossing point
which will automatically slow the the
vehicles down so there'll be a refuge
central refuge the speed limit on the
road is being reduced as well and that
was all agreed as part of the access at
the outlined stage and finally are you I
know you couldn't show it on the fly by
but liking is that being something you
will be taking taking forward there will
be street lighting on the site yes
councillor bondsman maybe not
appropriate that
the first thing the board member said
months ago but she was concerned about a
crossing from the side we were talking
about the road improvements I was going
to ask here but I'm trying to prove
what's being proposed is that you can go
across half of the road and wait in the
middle before you cross over to the
other side at the moment there isn't
anything and you've also got no
footpaths so you'll have a much safer
route across the road yeah thank you
thank you very much thank you if I could
now invite counsel Rolf to speak yeah
we'll let you know a 30 seconds of it
[Laughter]
actually whilst I do have time I can
answer to have your questions one is the
netting has now been removed by a
protest group and I don't know any of
them at all and the crossing that you
refer to was the crossing within the
site by the side of the teardrop and
that crossing Benson asked for that to
be closed off because there will be no
yes it's basically it's closed off the
crossing within the site is closed off
to make it safer
okay okay thank you okay so ladies and
gentlemen we are in a very different
position to where we were in December
Taylor Wimpey went away and took on
board everything you the committee said
and where's the working group set and
have come back with a better designed
and higher quality development spitfire
who were listening on that evening
decided that we were a tough group and
perhaps should put forward a better
development than they originally
intended after many months of meetings
with the planner and the developers we
are now in a situation where both the
developers have come forward for the
design scheme which is much more
acceptable to us and in turn to the
residents in telling t'en and the locke
syrota
one can almost say that wouldn't it have
been good if they put something like
this gold in the first place saving us
and their months and months of iteration
after iteration but here we are and I
must say thankfully during those months
both developers listen to us and made
several alterations to their schemes we
now have something that we can all
accept there are a few outstanding
issues which some of us have and we hope
that both Spitfire and Taylor Wimpey
continued to work with us on ironing out
some details we need that promise of
some developers have a reputation of
doing what they want once permission is
granted I hope that a working
relationship continues we did send
Victoria a list of conditions and we
hope that they will all be included and
I hope that committee asked about those
conditions it during their debate and I
also think that you should pursue the
issue of the golf club I think it's very
very important I want to give credit to
spit for iron Taylor Wimpey something I
never thought I would say about
developers
they did listen and well they had to
listen and I believe that this has been
an extremely good example of how
developments should evolve in the future
if developers work closely with
interested parties that it wouldn't have
wasted your time in the first place
if any of you want to replicate such
workings with developers then please do
contact me and I will help set up this
level of relationship with developers
that should have been there from the
beginning if elected I will make sure
that all new councillors are aware of
what could happen if compromise between
all parts of states place ok ok I also
know that the plan of Victoria has
welcomed this involvement and because of
this has made her life easier
although along the way it has been quite
intense with hundreds of emails flying
around and several meetings taking place
I personally would like to thank
Victoria for all the work she has put in
to this over the last several months we
are now where we are and even though the
working group of myself never wanted
this development to take place all those
years ago we have at least over a period
of time got to a place of compromise
leading to a better quality development
and a better thoughtful designed
environment Thank You council organ
thank you going back to the issue of the
golf club adjoining the top boundary
there we heard from mr. McDonald about
the requirement that that area should be
fenced off as a cordon sanitaire because
of stray golf balls and that you did
agree with that can you tell me is that
in your list of conditions that you
would like to be considered and what
area do you think should be cordoned off
and how would you mitigate against the
visual effect of a 2 meter fence okay
firstly I'm not sure it is in the list
of conditions but if it isn't it should
be but I believe you might debate this
of what could happen
it's a very it's a very difficult one
because it takes a long time for trees
to grow and I don't know whether offense
would work I know that Taylor Wimpey and
the golf club are in discussions on how
they're going to mitigate this and I
think there should be a level of
mitigation put in place I do think there
really should be but I'm not sure how
it's going to be basically I have I have
left it to the golf club to discuss the
table with me how far it would go and I
believe they are working with them on it
that's as far as I know but I do think
there should be a condition if there
isn't one after your debate thank you
any other questions No thank you Council
roll any questions for officers council
fielding socially a question for
councillor Perry do you know how far a
ball goes when it goes across that
surround house walking thank you
we heard from mr. McDonald that
condition 28 of the original grant of
our time was mentioned could someone
please read out condition 28 to me
certainly so this was imposed by the
planning inspector on the outline
application and it says prior to the
commencement of development within zone
3 of the development master plan zoning
and landscape sections drawing from the
draw numbers given for details of the
level a means of management of public
access to the area identified on the
open space and potential attenuation
shall be submitted to and approved in
writing by the local planning authority
and development implemented in
accordance with the approved details and
thereafter very there and retained
thereafter the reason for that condition
was to safeguard from the potential from
harm from stray golf balls from the
adjacent golf
in the interest of Public Safety so
fundamentally those details have to be
submitted prior to the commencement of
development they're not required to be
submitted as part of a reserved matters
application and they are for they
haven't been submitted at this point and
it would be for consideration in the
future maybe I can follow up on that so
because the issue has been raised I
would do beer to assist with what sort
of things are likely to satisfy the
discharge of that condition what are the
normal type of things that could be put
in place to manage the risk here so I
think that the inspector had obviously
considered the location of this site in
relation to the golf club in imposing
that condition and felt that obviously
it could be dealt with via some sort of
level means of management I think it
would be good to insist on some sort of
ball strike assessment as part of that
condition to understand the number of
golf balls that are likely to come into
this area and from where I believe that
such a thing is possible I don't believe
that the inspector had intended for this
to be fully fenced off if he had I would
have expected a condition to say this
area should be fenced off in total
there's a whole raft of measures that
could be put forward for that condition
you could put a slightly high offence
perhaps with a gate to a notice to
suggest that you know that this area he
may find it's straight golf balls or
golf balls makeup but as happens across
lots of the country where there's public
rights-of-way through golf clubs and the
likes but I would expect there to be a
level of detail submitted so that
there's an understanding as to the
likelihood of golf balls entering the
area and then appropriate mitigation to
be put forward to alleviate that thank
you
question can I also just add in terms of
looking at the landscape detail of that
particular area of the site additional
tree planting has been proposed
and quite specifically no part of in
that area and there's no play space in
that area so it's not seemed to be a
destination element so in terms of
assessing the reserved matters
application I don't see there being any
direct conflict to then looking at the
discharge condition going forward
councilor bond so this is diminishing
effect I honestly don't know I think
that logic could dictate that the more
trees there are the higher they are the
more likely they are to detect counts of
fielding my point is that if you defense
off that area until such time as the
trees reach a certain height and then
create rides and picnic areas within it
it would then mitigate being hit by a
golf ball for debate no further
questions okay I put it up to debate
councillor Richards thank you it seems
the system works
we finally have managed to get to an
agreement with all predominantly all
parties on this development which is
hugely positive beyond the golf ball if
you it's common practice across the
country for any golf club who have holes
to the side of either road or
development to put a net a mesh net to
prevent balls going in I see no reason
why that wouldn't be an appropriate
thing to put actually to the side of
that area to prevent balls going in at
all not only will that stop people
getting hit but actually the golfers
that do end up hitting it either keep
their ball in play or they'll find their
three pound ball which will keep them
very happy so I'm as you mentioned
that's for a condition to come forward
I'm sure the golf club and the
applicants will discuss that in more
depth as and when they bring that
forward so I'm entirely happy and
satisfied that this meets the criteria
in terms of planning and would
for all three that we go with offers
recommendation and grant in line with
the report and any updates and
conditions count you might have to do is
consider the application separately not
least because if Kat counselor Perry I
can come to that in due course perhaps
once people spoken like yeah I think my
understanding is that we will have to
understand thank you that's very helpful
counselor organ yes my concern having
had some experience of the situation at
lking Gardens is that there is something
actually written into the decision to
mitigate against this so I would like to
be advised when the appropriate time to
put this forward is probably now if you
if you think there ought to be a note
that goes along with any approval of
items the third item that we're looking
at here I use a Spitfire half yeah it's
probably best you suggest thank you well
if we could consider a note please that
it's something along the lines that
there is appropriate mitigation to
counter any identified risk following a
whatever the technical term for it is
thank you
so you finished ok counts the bombs I
spent two hours on one application and
it was a disgrace to be honest against
the rope knows Spitfire we had an
application in my Bridge three years was
up for the outline permission and in the
end they did come to the round the table
they did do exactly what we wanted and
the edges are not to be more than a
point
one metres tall we also showed them on
the tractor as we can measure the height
of the the has is quicker than
enforcement can I'm using the computer
that does the thing and the other thing
most well could golf course they've got
a beat thing that if it's going out now
I don't know much about it but it's next
to the Caliban site so what I'm saying
is in technical terms there could be
something that goes beep if the ball
quick goes over the fence well very much
like the tractor I mean you put the
tractor in the field the computer tells
you what to do you do what and so we can
tell the exact fire of all those houses
and garages quicker than spit farther so
we can keep it on so but the beep might
be something that has a note you would
want fielding sounds if we're gonna have
a firewall a bomb alert warden going on
I think if we could think about planting
more trees at a certain height and allow
them to develop it would be the way
around it but I'm in favor of the whole
project I would really like to propose
the first and the second and the third
is being acceptable
perhaps you want to second them thank
you I'm I'll just comment actually I
think I've seen this committee and
others defer items and actually they
come back with very little change and
actually you get developers very
resistant to make substantial
modification particularly to things like
layout and what they do is tinker around
the edges and say we've listened to
we've come back so actually I think the
applicant deserve a great deal of credit
for having made substantive changes so
I'm very very pleased with that so in
light of having a proposer and seconder
for each application
I would propose to take each application
in turn so people can either participate
or not but I just want to check on each
in taking each application that we've
got the appropriate conditions and we're
satisfied on each one so to deal with
the first one which is 18 / 0 2 5 8 - am
i right that's the first one so just so
I'm clear are the conditions that relate
to that there on page 49 and 50 of the
report
oh that was that was the obvious rapport
sorry so it's at page 33 that that
recommendation you have commences thank
you okay so from it's this application
is proposed for grant all those in favor
councillor bonds are you voting all you
all those in favor yeah thank you
therefore this committee resolved to
grant application 18 / 0 2 5 8 2 if we
can now move to application 18 / 0 2 6 3
9 there is a proposal to grant the
application all those in favor we did
councillor fielding and then to move to
the third application which is 18 such 0
3 4 5 5 with I would ask whether
councilor riches is happy to add to his
proposal that there is a note that
committee are concerned to make sure
that appropriate mitigation is put in
place to counter any identified risk as
in a ball strike assessment is put in
place in order to satisfy that condition
yeah that's fine I think he's covered by
this anyway but yes thank you
and second is happy with happy with that
okay therefore there is a proposal for
the grant of that application all those
in favor
thank you therefore this committee
resolves to grant application 18 such 0
3 4 5 5
committee will now deal with application
18 / 0 3 2 1 2 relating to Appleton
house snitterfield
thank you so yes we will turn to the
master of Appleton house and I invite
officers to make the appropriate
presentation thank you
Thank You chair good evening this is a
full play application for the erection
of one dwelling a garage the realignment
of vehicle access and associated
development this application site is
within the built-up area boundary of
this the village of Smithfield to the
north of Church Road as illustrated by
the black dots on this plan here we see
the application boundary outlined in red
one can see the conservation area
signified by the purple boundary part of
the application site incorporates in the
visibility displays here it's actually
within the sphere conservation area
boundary one can also see a smattering
of listed buildings highlighted in red
here and here we see a satellite image
of the application sites signified by a
red arrow here we have a its you
probably don't realize it so echoey it's
it's it's really picking up over here
and it's it's we're struggling to hear
sorry no I know you didn't mean it's
alright thank you right here we have the
what is the approved site layout plan
for Planning Commission reference 16 ref
4 / o 267 1/4 / fu well this was for the
seven houses and associated works one
can see the relationship here of the
proposed siting of the property here in
relation to both the allowed scheme for
seven and also Appleton house here
fronting fronting Church Road here we
see this relationship in more detail
showing the approved plot number one
here which is the closest dwelling the
subsidy B application building here the
subject of this application here we have
the site layout so pick upon the site
layout plan as proposed we see there's a
garage in addition to the indicated
position of bin collection
the purple lines you see on your plan
there also indicates the indicative
personal fencing
here we have the front and side
elevations is proposed one can see there
a traditional brick and tile with wooden
frames and likewise the side and rear
elevations here we have a proposed
streetscape elevation plan as viewed
from the public highway on Church Road
we now have a few photos of the site's
and its surroundings
here we are stood on Church Road looking
Northwest words one can see by virtue of
the temporary construction tower and
Porter cabin there that is the
indicative approximate sighting of the
develop where this proposed dwelling is
proposed to be sited here we are now
looking at largely the same image other
than to see the existing trees of
vegetation that are proposed to be
retained as part of this application now
we are looking at the Northeast which
direction from the existing driveway of
a dwelling a neighboring dwelling
opposite on the opposite side the road
and here at now we all stood on the
footpath directly opposite of sites one
could see the access Drive here of the
neighboring property armed and house in
addition to the existing trees to be
retained and a small smidgen of the
opposite house property on the far right
here we are now stood on the site itself
in between a person house and the bread
opposed application buildings to be
located here we're looking Northwest
woods towards the application site for
the approved 70 Wellings I'm walking to
see it's in a very much an active
construction sites at the time for this
meeting chair that including concludes
my presentation I'd like to invite you
to please refer to the update sheet for
details on updates for this application
chair my recommendation is to grant this
application for the reasons I felt pages
106 and 107 degrees in the pack thank
you if I could now invite miss Kimberly
from the parish council to speak
thank you you have three minutes when
you start speaking yeah right I did ask
if we could have the street scene
displayed and the parish council objects
the application we have a policy in our
neighborhood plan h3 that development on
garden land for Appleton house in this
case will only be supported if it
condemn ins be demonstrated that the
proposal will not significantly and
demonstrably harm the amenity of the
host dwelling or and neighboring
properties now on this particular plan
you'll see the new proposed house on the
left and it does show the ground level
of that house is it possible to zoom and
show the ground level indicate the
ground level for the new house that's
the ground level and I'd point out the
car beneath it on Church Road now we
believe the position of this house
because of the topography the height of
it a grand level in relation to the
neighboring property Elms own house will
be harmful to the amenity of Emden house
I've also asked for photograph to be
displayed photograph 3 thank you the
actual site Appleton house is behind the
boarded fence you can see there behind
Appleton house so the ground level of
the site is roughly at the first floor
level of Appleton house now I put on
house at this part of the house is one
and a half stories but once you get into
the site the main part of the house is
the regular two stories two stories plus
a pitched roof now the developers flag
can be seen in on the skyline just above
the fence
below the bow of the tree so that's how
close it is but the actual house the
rear elevation of the proposed new house
will look over to the rear garden of
Elgin house and we think the difference
in height between these buildings which
represents an extra story will lead to
overlooking potential light pollution
and possibly noise pollution which would
have a detrimental effect on the
residential amenity of this neighboring
property and that this application
against thank you very much for
listening we object it's against a
policy h3 thank you thank you
councillors any questions no this is on
the curtilage of the house as is the the
development for the seven houses is
behind Appleton house and I don't know
how much of that land behind Appleton
house was garden curtilage but certainly
not all of it but that's another
application and I can't answer that
question accurately but in respect of
this particular new house it's the
garden curtilage slab and an extra one
yes it's looking over the the elevation
faces the rear garden abandoned houses
here thank you very much thank you
thank you if I could now invite mr.
Murphy on behalf of the applicant mr.
Murphy you have three minutes thank you
the site is located within the
settlement power juice tutor field and
is part of the garden to an existing
house comprising a pool hard standing
pergola and ornamental planting limited
infilling is allowed in Greenbelt
villages and therefore in principle it
is acceptable to build a house on this
site furthermore council policy seeks to
seek to make more efficient use of land
and therefore building a house on
redundant garden land is a benefit to
the district councillor Richards refers
to a planning application for ten houses
at Appleton house refused in 2015
however the core strategy and the
neighborhood plan have been adopted
since then this proposed house lies
outside the application site for the ten
houses and it needs to be determined on
its merits we have drawn a street scene
plan and it is an accurate plan and it
deliberately Oh miss Hamilton house
located to the left of Appleton house
this plan simply helps to identify the
relative height of the proposed house to
Appleton house and the two houses sit at
approximately the same Ridge height a
realistic view from Church Road looking
towards the proposed house is as follows
firstly mature trees and hedges on the
church road frontage next is the house
and garage of Elms and house beyond that
is the existing Appleton house and
beyond that is the proposed house which
is 52 metres away from the road and
taking account of rising ground levels
the proposed house will be almost
invisible from the public domain and in
my view it doesn't form a part of the of
the Church Road Street seen seven houses
are currently under construction on
adjacent land to the Northwest and the
proposed house will share is vehicular
access from Church Road therefore the
new private drive serving the proposed
house has already been
and constructed when those seven new
houses are completed the proposed house
will be positioned in a part of the
village with housing all around in that
context the proposed house will
successfully assimilate with its
surroundings finally in terms of
residential immunity the proposed house
is located 28 meters away from Elm Dan
house in excess of council separation
standards that recommends a minimum of
21 metres between two-story houses the
proposed garden for the new house
measures 280 square metres whereas the
council's minimum standard for measuring
house is 62 square metres so about four
times smaller indeed all of the council
standards are met in terms of
residential immunity for existing and
future residents now therefore the
officers recommendation to grant should
be upheld and planning permission
granted
thank you thank you mr. Murphy any
questions no it's the garden to Upton
House so what's happened etcd yet the
access roads
basically the access roads going in to
serve the seven houses has severed the
garden to Appleton house into so this is
now basically a redundant garden so it
was the garden to Upton House the new
Drive has gone in that's shown on that
plan and so there's leftover garden land
that really doesn't serve anyone because
the parish council seemed to indicate it
wasn't garden land or wasn't part of
Appleton house go well it was part of
the gardens Wahpeton house gateway the
fence
timber fence seem to be right on top of
the house and yet from that drop drawing
it well I have trouble recognizing the
context of that photograph I think that
the one with the gate
yeah actually if you do go back corn
that that's clearly the view from from
Church Road so I think you see a glimpse
of the clothes boarded fence but of
course the proposed house is 28 meters
beyond that deeper going further away
from the camera
that's that sounded house so I think
plants away which the office had up
before showed that this proposed house
at 28 meters further away there you go
from Elms and house yes yeah yeah that
distance of 28 meters
today's 50 s 50 it's about 52 meters
from from the road there any more
questions thank you miss Murphy
councillor Richards you have five
minutes
Thank You Jay so members sit in order to
make a fully informed decision on this
application I think is it vital that you
have a full comprehensive understanding
of the planning history to this site
many of you will recall previous
application of the rev Appleton house
for seven homes for which many of this
committee attended a site visit and
resolve to refuse planning permission on
the grounds that seven homes would not
constitute a small-scale development in
the village in his field that they
identified harm to the Greenbelt by
virtue I was in appropriateness and
impact on the openness should be
afforded significant weight with no
benefit public benefit to outweigh that
harm that the introduction of a new
entrance and the loss therefore of a
wall and soft lands gained him would not
reflect that a distinctive
distinctiveness of the locality and that
developments it developments sighting
and property Heights would cause
significant impact on the conservation
area and result in harm to the Harriton
heritage assets surrounding the site
prior to refusal of that application was
a refusal of a scheme for ten homes
which mr. Mathias referred to just now
on the same site the refusal reasons
the same for that as it was to the seven
and the most prominent of those reason
has been the size of the development not
being of small scale regrettably in 2017
in an inspector concluded that the
scheme for seven homes would be
acceptable and so permission was granted
however he was quite clear in his report
that he did not afford the sniff field
NDP any weight at all given it at that
stage it was not yet adopted that Andy
Pina is now fully adopted and it's in my
opinion that his decision would have
been very different had he afforded it
wait specifically that the land Appleton
house was considered during the NDP
process and not identified as a site for
development within the final NDP where
other sites were the reason I feel it is
important you understand that history as
they become as it it becomes ever
clearer that this is a speculative
application attempting to get even
closer to the originally refused scheme
larger scheme on the site the refusal
for the reason for refusal for both
schemes remain unchanged and with NDP
now given full weight those reasons are
further reinforced by agreeing to this
development now we are essentially given
the green light to the largest gain
through the back door and sending a
message to developers that this is an
accepted practice by this council it is
not an accepted practice and therefore
this application should be refused to
the regions previously given in my
opinion the site is already over
development there over developed and has
caused significant harm to the area and
the residents surrounding that site the
addition of yet another dwelling would
further compound that harm and should be
refused on the grounds of over
development in addition the addition
Tauri of a new dwelling in this location
would also have a harmful impact on the
conservation area and the cumulative
impact of the seven homes already
granted plus this additional eight home
generates sufficient harm to be refused
there are no public benefits of an
additional single dwelling to outweigh
harm and finally I've concern over the
proposed sighting that property
specifically in regard to overlooking
over bearing to the neighboring property
of Elm Dan house as the parish council
has already put forward to you and
proposed amenity space of the property
itself being adequate for the future
occupiers before this proposed Welling
not only am i objecting the price
counselor objected and over 30 members
of the public have written to object
including the CP re there is a clear
message from residents that the planning
should be refused for the reasons I have
given I employee to do the right thing
give full weight to the opinions of the
residents of Snyder field and their
adopted an EP and refused a planning
permission Thank You councillor Richards
do you think there would be any merit
the parish council made reference to the
different levels of the topography do
you think there's any merit in having
deferred and having a site visit by the
Committee on the basis that number of
the committee you know they would be new
people coming in do you think there's
there's any merit to the application
that we should look to consider a site
visit I think the committee would make
it we have now a very experienced that
be were part of the decision making the
majority of you will be part of the
decision making of over the seven
properties welling behind it of called
land to the back of map stone house and
we conducted a site visit then it was
abundantly clear to all the topography
of that land was such that it would have
an overbearing impact on neighboring
residents and I think this is is much
the same here I can understand why one
would want to have a site visit
certainly the the drawings that we've
seen certainly give the impression of
much more space there than there
actually is if you're struggling to make
a decision then by all means defer for a
site visit I think there is enough
evidence enough reason to refuse without
the need to go for that aside was it in
particular that you can tell the site
that the change in levels from the photo
again provided by Cathy Kimberly of the
parish council of Alden house the gates
filmed in-house leading up to that fence
it's significant that's almost the
entirety of the height of Elm Dan house
in changes of levels if that doesn't
give you enough information then by all
means go for a site visit but I think
that is sufficient to make a decision
the bonds yes
am I right or wrong this site is on the
top of the bank actually I think I went
to the site visit many years ago and the
point is that it does appear that 10 12
have been refused they then put him for
seven and got it on appeal and it looks
as though they're trying to sneak
another word in and telling us that the
plots big enough I think you're
absolutely right you nailed it you'll
have seen in your update sheet that
there's an issue in terms of enforcement
over the ground levels and topography
I'm going to propose to go into detail
of that because I think it would be
inappropriate to do so but clearly
there's the there is an issue intend to
fight and first of you that did come for
the site visit previously and have since
been to the site you you will know the
the change in levels from that top road
from the top of Appleton house down to
Belle Lena Barbara we don't have the
full wording of the appeal for the seven
which may help us decide which way we go
with these applications
is there a question because it's not
really about things that you would like
to know from the appeal decision I'm
sure that can be something it's directed
towards offices if there's a question
I'm happy but okay all right thank you
thank you okay questions for the offices
councillor bonds planning sudden has
gone through presumably because this is
smaller number in your eyes they can
whatever the inspector said allowing
this happen well the wording help us for
guidance on the eggs I think it would -
sir eyes the inspector concluded that
seven additional planning since litter
field was small-scale and was infill on
this particular site he said the seven
homes present proposed sorry represent a
very small proportion brackets about 1.5
percent of the total 450 drawings
requirement across the ten LSPs and a
modest share around twelve percent of
snitterfield assumed maximum
contribution of 59 dwellings policy
cs50.net vices that the scale of housing
development appropriate in each village
is as specified in CS 16 the council has
therefore identified knitted field as
being suitable to accommodate a
significant share he carries on the
proposal for seven dwellings is a small
scale scheme in that context officers in
considering the addition of one more a
scheme of eight in total remains in that
a bit in this still small scale given
the findings of the private inspector in
that respect organ Thank You chairman do
are there any levels drawings which show
probably a section just below the road
parallel with the bottom that goes
through so have Elden house is it and
the proposed new house throw there the
short answers know that there isn't a
site section plan rates what your
authority with written from the suite of
documents in this application do you
then have measurements evidence
measurements levels I have a thoughts I
mean this plan here for example this is
a suite a plan provided by the
applicants I can give you I can't give
you some measurements related to the
actual property proposed there is
essentially a four meter change
elevational change from standing from
Church Road looking at the viewing in
other words way to view the top measure
the top of the ridge height of the
property was viewed on Church Road it is
four meters higher than the actual
dwelling itself so I interpret to be an
approximate four meter level change the
heights the ridge in total for the
dwelling is five point two meters when
you measure that from from this street
game plan its equates to approximate for
me to difference when viewed mistreating
I just seek clarification further
clarification we're talking about from
street level we're showing it in
comparison with Apple turn but nowhere
do we see it in comparison with for
instance levels on Alden I think what
might be instructive for members to
consider in that respect is the
comparative Ridge Heights between
the proposed property and Appleton house
bearing that in mind and then sorry
returning to these images which show
Appleton house and the context of the
new driveway which has been created the
approximate position of the dwelling
being where this container is so fit set
further back from Appleton house and
then maneuvering around the site you can
see the photo presented by the parish
council that's the front corner of elm
Dhin house and the property would be set
back considerably from there as the
agent set out so you can see in this
plan here that there's some considerable
distance between that gable proposed and
the view which is taken in by the photo
we were just considering which is
effectively through here with this
location roughly being the position of
the closed board fence that you were
observing and then the siting of the
house this square here effectively thank
you I think that's clarified Thank You
councillor Perry Thank You chair I'd
just like some clarification obviously
it's it is classified in the committee
report as West Midlands Greenbelt can
you
therefore clarify what the special
circumstances are for building on the
plot and also the weight we can give to
the adopters that afield the
neighborhood development plan I'll take
those in reverse order if it's okay cuz
the first is very short answer Miss
Anita field NDP is made it has full
weight it's part of the development plan
and should form the starting point for
decision-making in the context of
planning applications in respect of this
application with regard to greenbelt the
application is in officers view the
limited in filling within a Greenbelt
village that is a form of development
which is not considered inappropriate
within our own core strategy and within
national planning policy therefore there
is no need for the developer to
demonstrate very special circumstances
it is by its nature appropriate
development this is not therefore
harmful to the Greenbelt question
Worcester on the neighbourhood plan so
it's been said by the parish councils
that essentially their neighbourhood
plan is not for the building of God on
land if it won't harm the immediate
unity of the host or neighboring
properties so in what way in light of
your proposal to grant the application
in what way do you consider this
proposed to be compliant with then the
NDP as set out in the committee report
we considered that the immunity of the
host House Appleton house and the
neighboring house Alden house is
safeguarded by the separation distances
between the properties concerned it's
correct to say that h3 sets out that
development on garden land can only be
supported if amenity is harmed officers
have considered that and don't find that
there is harm there isn't there is an
acceptable harm in this respect I think
officers are mindful of the scale of the
proposed property which you can take in
virus reviewing this plan here in
respective alden house in Appleton house
and in respect of the approved
properties which are all significantly
larger than this property
and from the elevations which I think
Stewart mentioned this is a little over
five and a half meters so around five
point two meters to the eaves a little
further to the reject and a half meters
to the ridge in that respect it's an
appropriate scale in offices view so the
likely impact on immunity not
disconcerting in that respect
just as a follower you not concerned
about the fact that it's on higher
ground and it's been it's talked about I
mean I think we can see there's quite a
significant distance between the
property and home Dan house but it's
been referred to about overlooking in
terms of the garden is a concern or
consideration it's certainly a
consideration it's something that
officers do consider when looking at
planning applications in respective
direct impacts from overlooking garden
land we consider the area within 10
metres of the rear of a property to be
the most sensitive areas of garden land
so you know within 10 metres of the rear
valentín house we would consider that to
be you know more sensitive than the area
which is likely to be overlooked than by
this dwelling in particular the building
this area when they put it when they've
put in their first application or their
application for 7 which was granted by
appeal what was this bit of land then
was it left out of what was going
forward or why wasn't it involved to
give it the as part of them of the
original applicant I think it was
outside of the redline boundary on that
basis it's not clear what the
expectation for the land was or whether
they thought that this where they always
thought this was likely to come forward
for an additional dwelling it's not
clear myself for the current case
officer handled that application so you
can know that
can't confirm either way unfortunately
Chancellor Atkinson there's been a lot
of talk about the seven it's interesting
background but in my short years 27
present counselor I've always been
taught look at each application on its
merits the seven is reasonable
background but times have changed since
then we now have these your question
counts right consumer day I don't want
you saying any of this in debate but is
there a question for offices yeah I am
if I can have the chance
the site is identified in the
neighborhood development plan exactly
correct not only that it's within the
built up area boundary is that correct
just a clarify that point it's not
identified as a site per se for anybody
to vote and there it is you are correct
it is included within the boundary but
it on your first point it's not
unidentified it's not I did say it's
within the neighborhood which is a major
a major factor could we then have a look
at the one where you have the Ridge
Heights before and am i right in
thinking that from what's the name of it
foundin house the proposal is over to
the right as we look at it you said you
did on the right and here and in that
you look at sort of 10 meters away this
is about 14 and a half
I this proposed property is
approximately 30 meters away from Elm
dirt house to the left of this imagery
here about 30 meters upper 30 yeah I see
but it standard is 10 I think in in
respect at the 10 meters what we are
saying is that the most sensitive area
of a garden is the area within 10 meters
of the rear end of the property but am i
right who's thinking this is 13 yes okay
which was quite an increased gem yes you
can save and debate yep you've also got
icy foliage there as well that is a
shielding factor okay so really some of
the complaints here by the parish
council seem to be irrelevant don't have
to comment on that 630 30 meters yeah
any other questions
no I'll open up to debate chelsea
fielding
having lost it appear when the we are
refused it I have a horrible feeling
that this would again if went repeal
would have the same results and
therefore I'm quite happy to propose
that we go along with the officers
recommendation sorry
Thank You Jen
in contrast to my colleague sitting
opposite I'm concerned about this
application I think as a as a district
council we have done absolutely
everything to encourage parish councils
to work hours and hours and hours to
produce neighborhood development plans I
believe the core strategy is all about
interpretation and in my view whilst we
have policy cs10 on the Greenbelt say
limited in filling in local service
villages identified in accordance with
policy CS 16 when I then turned to
policy CS 16 it then says the council is
committed to giving local people the
opportunity to influence where homes are
built in their communities and
encourages parish councils to prepare
neighbourhood plans that identify sites
to meet or exceed the housing
requirements set out above we have a
situation this evening where we have
strong parish council objection we have
strong ward member objection we have a
an adopted parish a neighbourhood plan
which carries full weight and we have a
situation this site in Greenbelt Belt
and I feel that cumulatively
you take on board the neighbourhood plan
and the Greenbelt issue we have grounds
for refusal if I come in there remember
the site very well of them don't know if
we even had to site visits to it and
actually I still don't like the original
application I don't and the reasons are
because it's in that area where all the
houses that surround it have to look in
on it and I just didn't I just don't
like the format of it but I have to say
this particular house was never going to
be an in-house Alissa's the location was
never an aspect
had it been part of the original
application that personally concerned me
because I felt in that location in my
field it has a limited impact on the the
front view it's quite well buried into
the site unlike the other housing which
is overlooked by those properties in
that Bellbrook area this doesn't have
that I understand what you're saying
count sorry about the neighborhood
development plan but my understanding
about the the NDP's are that they don't
they set out preferred sites but it's
not a complete we will literally set
down every single site and only the
sites on which there can be building
there is of course always going to be
some suggestion that there may be a site
that comes for one house and so I think
the issue is is it limited infill is it
does it infringe green box and I think
the issue here is that actually in terms
of limited infill if if inspector has
said seven houses is limited and fill
one house certainly would be considered
Li limited infill so I think it's
probably is Greenbelt compliant it's
within the Builder very boundary and I
think in general terms if you take a
common-sense assessment I have to say I
don't I don't feel it has a very
significant impact on the character of
the area in the way that that of the
site as I say that I still don't like I
think has so I have to say even though I
completely agree with you and you and
you know that I'm always incredibly
respectful of local plans and making
sure they're adhered to I'm not actually
convinced this isn't compliant because
it says it won't God and land is it is
permitted to build on it if it won't
harm the immunity and let's be honest
it's a very long way from armed and
house and it's a long way from Appleton
house but that's just my two minutes
with councillor Barnes just wangle an
extra house in the green belt they tried
to attain they got seven they've got a
space he's overlooking he isn't greatly
overlooking but it's against the PI's
plan so we may lose it appeal but that
isn't the point point is the risk
concern and I'm for everything second
what if ever the proposal was or wasn't
previously
yeah did you want to say anything counts
Watkinson
did you want to say anything or was it
just the seconding yeah okay so is
anyone else want to add icing to the
debate because otherwise I think I'm
going to go to the Vosges I would
propose to vote on counts the Fielding's
proposal first because it came first and
then if relevant we'll turn to the
second one okay so the proposal from
councilor fielding seconded by
Councillor Atkinson is to grant
application 18 / 0 3 2 1 2 all those in
favor all those against 2 German thank
you therefore this committee resolves to
grant the application
right committee one more short
application return to 1900 four nine one
full which is relates to Ridge Street
stratford-upon-avon and I invite office
to make relevant presentation if
everyone's ready the District Council so
we have to hear this one
the applicant is the District Council so
we have to hear this one it's short
Thank You chair this application is a
full planning application for the change
of use of land to hold temporary markets
for up to forty three days per year the
application site lies in the center of
stratford-upon-avon identified by the
black dot on the plan the site is
located within the heart of the
conservation area of Stratford town
several listed buildings lining either
side of the road the eastern part of the
site for joining waterside is in flood
zones two and three this is the
applicant site plan with the red line
area delineating the land which is
proposed to be used for temporary
markets Market stores will be erected
within this area I now have a couple of
photos of the site here we stood at the
eastern part of Bridge Street looking up
towards the application site with
Barclays Bank in the distance this photo
is taken to the west of Bridge streets
with Barclays Bank behind me looking
down towards the application site there
are no updates to the application chair
the recommendation is to grant the
application subject to the conditions
set out on pages 1 1 8 and
nine of the agenda so there are new
speakers on this application does anyone
have any questions for officers no good
right debate 1500 some being told yes
council fielding yes I would just note I
think the part about the the applicant
being advised at all pace pavement
should be clearing a novice directed at
all times I think it's important given
the issues that have been raised by
disability advisor so is there a
seconder for that you know I despise
retrospective planning applications and
I think the applicant should have known
better I assume he will be okay right
so in seriousness now the application
before us is that at 9500 for nine one
there is a proposal to grant met
application all those in favor
unanimous chair thank you this committee
resolves to grant can we wish a happy
birthday for the chair meeting closed